recently joe biden said we are going to
be facing a very dark
winter we're now hearing that dr fauci
is saying we're going to be facing the
surge
of surges surge of surges there you go
the surge of search
in europe they've been locking down it's
been quite ridiculous in greece you got
to text the cops you want to leave your
home in france they're saying you got to
show your papers if you leave your house
no no joke
you leave your house you leave where you
live authority stop you've got to give
them documents proving you have a right
to leave your home
we heard in newark new jersey they were
saying they didn't want you to leave
your home for 10 days
there's not a whole lot they can do in
the united states though they're trying
and
the difficult thing is we have something
it's very beautiful it's a it's called
the constitution maybe you've heard of
it
and it really does allow us uh well it
constrains the government
it's not stopping despotic lunatics like
andrew cuomo and newsom
and and and wolf and murphy from doing
ridiculous things
but when it does make it to the courts
oftentimes these
all these governors are losing but then
they keep pushing
one of the most egregious uh um i
shouldn't even say egregious but there
have been several instances
coming out of new york where it really
does feel and this is my opinion
that bill de blasio and andrew cuomo
they really hate jewish people
so joining us today we've got heshi
tischler yeah correctly
yes you are and uh man i've heard a lot
about you
leading leading the charge fighting back
against unconstitutional
uh lockdown orders harassment abuse
tiffany tyranny outright tyranny you
know thank you tim for letting me come
on my show
and and i i i spoke about you come on
your show you should come on my show
and this way you know it's on wednesday
night nine o'clock which nobody knows by
the way everybody
uh but uh i want you to know uh
i i know you're gonna let me say what i
have to say but it's not just the jewish
people that i fight for
you know we are allowed to fight back
this is america just like you said
and and this guy governor cuomo and
mayor de blasio i know you don't want me
to say bad words but they are idiots you
got to let me say the word idiot
you call whatever you want okay i have
worse words to say but ian's gonna throw
something on me i see it in his hand
stop it
anyways but my problem here is that
these guys have a lot of money they have
a lot of lawyers you know that they have
you guys don't know this that inside our
government
they have lawyers that are able to go
around the constitution we have 30 40
bills a month
that passed just through the city
council not through the state
legislature and the assembly
their lawyers figure out a way to take
illegal laws and break
and i'm sitting there how do you break
the constitution well we figured out
with uh
state to state laws they figure things
out and i scream at them
i said you can't do this and i'm i you
know for 30 years i'm standing in the
background i help special needs kids and
children on the street and i've been
fighting the city for the city
against the city but what he's doing now
is this
like i said they're our leader they're
supposed to be a guide they think
they're our parents
i'm 56 years old you're not my father
i've raised 21 foster kids
i've have 105 nephews in these that's
right i got a lot of them
okay i'm building a beautiful family it
takes me a long time
i have my own babies my own
grandchildren i have kids that come
through my house daily i have
youth children how to how the heck okay
you got that you like that
youtube you heard that how the heck do
you have a right to take responsible
people that have served this country
that have served this community
we have more organizations in my
neighborhood you know my neighborhood
none of my stores are boarded up we have
we have our own securities we have our
own volunteer groups that we donate i'm
not talking one or two we have
we work with the police i work with the
police as you know i was arrested
yes you are yeah this well that's we'll
start from the beginning
oh we got a lot to talk about so ian's
sitting here hi everybody yes
thank you and lydia and ladies and
gentlemen i am over here oh hi lydia
yeah
smash the like button hit the subscribe
button and hit the notification bell
and uh so so they're they're
almost everything they're doing is
unconstitutional i mean
just to start the first amendment says
the right to peaceably assemble
it doesn't say for what if you want to
peaceably assemble because you guys are
having a pizza party
doesn't say anything otherwise but let's
start from the beginning they started
locking down
how did you get involved in activism and
what like what has a city been doing to
your community
and to the people of new york so march
april may june as you know the great
lockdown
uh my community tries to and i get
screamed up by the leaders
and now i'm telling them just to jump in
the lake because i've been one of those
guys behind the scenes
they scared because a lot of the bigger
people have money or they're getting
money from government grants
or a lot of them are paid off and i know
it because i see that the money coming
into the bigger guys
but when i have special needs kids they
get 15 dollars from insurance
when that when when they have to pay and
115 dollars to a doctor
three times a month we can't afford that
so you're talking these guys are getting
hundreds of millions of dollars driving
cadillacs
and we're getting nothing or some school
rabbi or a teacher
says you know just open my school but
but don't forget about the other 60 70
000 kids
how does a mayor open up a school for
for pre-k but not for fifth graders or
sixth graders it's
all the same you know that uh 99.5
get better children dying from covert is
like getting hit by lightning
but let's start from the beginning i did
listen i did cooperate of course i was
one of essential workers i
have my own radio show plus i help
people with the building department i
fight the city i'm also
as well as a volunteer for a food
program for
for families that need food on the
weekend i'm part of a few organizations
and of course i'm a volunteer i'm one of
the few volunteers that are still
allowed in the hospital because they're
scared of me i'm a big fat guy but
they're scared of me
but my problem here is we were quiet
march april may he kept extending his
stupid executive order we didn't know
what's going on this is the first time
this ever happened to us
so we listened to him june comes around
now i had a little park
i have a driveway and you know i don't
have a big house i have a couple of
floors
and i live in and we have some tenants
and we we're good to our people and i'm
good to the people on my block and we
again like i told you my house is open
you can come and eat whatever you want
except for linda's yogurt nobody can
touch linda's yogurt
they're seven dollars a piece guys
please i'm telling you she's not normal
okay
i love you linda if you're listening to
the show i was joking i was joking
no she's not a good cook no no she is
i'm lying i love you baby i'm dead meat
when i get home tim
you have a room for me i'm not going
home anyway we do actually thank god i'm
dead
anyways so i'm just telling you what
happened was is i made my driveway into
a little park for the kids i see the
kids on their bicycle they're running in
the streets
parents are calling because again i do a
lot of people behind the scenes people
with troubles anybody who calls me
can ask my phone rings till midnight i
get up 4 30 in the morning
and my phone is already ringing at six i
go to the hospital every morning
and i try to help the little things the
little things
get a bottle of milk for your neighbor
drop off a juice go visit for now and
these are the things that i do
a little volunteering stuff and i get
the kids in the youth center involved
that way
and you can save lives you can make
changes in people's lives
so um june comes around i see kids
running in the street
my son comes to me and my oldest son he
says to me he's not my older my last son
that i have at home and he says
i don't understand the parks are closed
it doesn't make sense i said i called
the assemblyman i saw i called the
mayor's liaison they hung up the phone
on me
i called the assemblyman i called the
state senator who was nowhere to be
found i make fun of him all the time
he's ready for his pension
i don't understand these guys nobody's
replying to me they're telling me we
can't help you or if you do something
we'll come after you they've threatened
to arrest me a few times
my son says to me i love my boy i try to
be a hero to him i have no wings
i'm no special angel and i'm going to
tell you a story about my father with
the angels but
i'm just a regular guy from the street
but i know ways to solve problems
don't be scared look at the light at the
end of the tunnel
i i don't like when there are bullies
out there pushing my friends around
and i'll be the bully i'll i'll fight
back so my son says
pap just cut the lock i said it doesn't
work like that he says why not
and i've been i've been a contractor for
20 something years so i walked into my
garage and i found this bolt cutter and
i asked my nephews i carried around with
me to this day i never give it up
and i drove to the park cut the locks a
couple of kids told me he said come on
in
and the parks department came and said
oh no i did research on the law the
governor says
the park could be open the mayor says it
can't be open
so when they're on the same page i'll
agree till then you can all jump in the
lake and then i drove around all the
neighborhoods and i see other parks open
why are the jewish parks and the jewish
neighborhoods open and i drove to crown
heights and yes he had some other parks
closed down
uh in other neighborhoods that were easy
people that you can push around
and the jewish people want to be quiet
they don't want to be
in the scene they don't want to make
noise it embarrasses me
sometimes they were shutting down the
parks in the jewish area
all the jewish every jewish park not
shut down
locked sealed double sealed when you
opened it up
they were there the next day you
understand they knew what was going on
they were watching and one day i just
started
the kids come protesting me and forget
the adults i bought the kids
and i opened the park and the parks guy
came and i said you're not coming in
here
and i had a big fight with him and he
called the police and of course the
chief is a friend of mine and the local
guys
i said i understand i will shut the park
myself let's drive down to 8th avenue
65th street 10 blocks away
you explain to me why that park was open
he walked over to the park sky
i understand is that true the park is
open he says well that's a different
area and the mayor said we have to close
this one i'm only all right
so i said listen to me you're not
shutting down my park take out your gun
shoot me if the bullet doesn't go
through be very careful cause i'm a big
fat guy he doesn't go through it
man okay uh and that's the way it
happened and what happened was is they
didn't close the park
everybody went home now my neighborhood
brooklyn in borough park especially
flatbush or may droid
everybody knows my number they call me
day and night i get hundreds of calls i
mean texts
emails i can't even keep up with it and
i try to call everybody back i'm not one
of those politicians that hides and i
have my office who gets angry at me
to help you know constituents and my
local residents
i don't do it for money i've been doing
it i have a regular job but i know what
it is to help a fellow man i was
a kid that lost his father when i was 13
years old
i had to raise my two brothers and down
syndrome sister i had to help a lot of
my friends in school i've been called
uncle hessian since i'm 15 years old
okay so i've been around the block me
and linda slept on the floor when we got
married you know what i mean i know what
it is to struggle
i see what other people go through and
sometimes a guy just needs a job
a guy just needs a helping hand a kid
needs a place to go hang out
go pick him up we have kids young boys
and girls hanging on the street i just
walk down come on home
come over my door is open take whatever
you want except for linda's yoga
but take whatever you want trust me
somebody took linda's last yogurt i was
in big trouble
yeah she was crying i said linda it's a
seven dollar yogurt i'll buy you
terrible i only get 20 allowance from
her but it cost me three yogurts
anyways so this is what i'm trying to
say so i cut a lot and then the next day
they snuck in from the back from the
other side this is a park that
i play kids play baseball with the kids
i know the park i know every inch of it
and that was the only part i was going
to open and i said you're not closing it
we had a big fight the police came again
and this time the big park ranger with
his gun came
this is the real guy that could actually
arrest me and i started talking with him
four minutes usually in my videos or two
minutes it was four minutes people were
filming it the whole community came you
know when there's a fight people come
running oh yeah
and he was a very nice ranger at the end
he says just shut up and listen to me
and he explained to me says you're right
the governor may are not on the same
page
says the park is yours and he points to
the guy says do not touch this park
and the guy says back we're not gonna
clean the park i said i don't need you
get out
don't clean the park just don't come
back here again and every day i had my
park watched
and then i got calls from crown heights
i got calls from uh far rockaway
i got called from williamsburg when not
only did they close the park you're
gonna love this
they welded the gates shut
i said really do you actually think that
he'll stop me i go there i cut the lock
and the big fat man could just push open
the gate and we did it and the police
were standing there
they thanked me they watched me in crown
heights they tried to arrest me five cop
cars
and then a little black kid comes over
me slaps me five and says thank you
hashi
cops turned around and left and the
mayor couldn't take it i
fight 312 government agencies daily you
know what it is the red tape the lies
from foster care from building
department vacating people
having all people being thrown out of
their homes homeowners losing their
houses
city finding them you know we have 31
million dollars in fines in three weeks
because the mayor and governor want to
teach my neighborhood a lesson
listen man governor do whatever you want
yes i have to say idiot
i'm gonna get you i'm here i'm going to
get into my city council
i hope you will mind me saying
heshitishla.com guys
i need money i want to win this and i
don't want to win this i want to crush
this when i get into the city council
i need 26 new councilmen there's 35
coming in
i'm going to take over the city council
i'm going to teach the mayor a lesson
i'm never going to let them do this
again to my city and it's you know we
had the senior citizens dying
because they have no uh they have no
concept
of what they're doing they have no
proper i have the numbers i
go you know they told me 48 people died
they told me
17 people uh have covered new cases now
here's your problem guys
i'm in the hospital every morning i walk
their beds there's one
you're talking i'm friends with the
funeral parlor guys they told me there
was two funerals two old people that did
not have covert
now i have no idea so they're saying oh
[ __ ] you only know your hospital in
borough park
so then i drove to flatbush koniana
hospital
i walked in there and of course my
friend is one of the people who works in
the er he gave me the whole outfit
strolled around nobody knew what i was
doing
again bed's empty all over the place i
thought well over capacity
when was that now two weeks ago last
week and i've been doing it
since june since june i'm going every
day to the hospital
now i have friends in the bronx who are
telling me half the hospital's open
when when we opened up you remember the
great javits center that was supposed to
be overloaded with people
i went there out of the thousand or
three thousand beds 300 beds were being
used
and there was no food for kosher people
i went there i made a video i screamed
and hollered you'll never get it and the
soldiers won't let you in
soldiers were delicious they were
wonderful they came out they took my
boxes
i had people bringing me boxes from all
over the place i got them in there
and i gave of course to the soldiers and
of course my policemen just protected me
they're wonderful people
i am a person that believes the right
thing should always be done and no
matter what it takes you want to put me
in jail go ahead it's one guy
but you're not going to torture my
people i'm not going to have kids in
front of my youth center which we had
and i'm gonna tell you put himself on
fire i have 97 suicides no no not in new
york city my son
in my neighborhood you know what it is
yeah i have to go see the family
or i have to be one of the violence it's
not only me you think i'm i'm being
not serious or i'm sad or i'm one of
those guys who are not tough i am tough
i've been on the streets i
i've worked myself up i've been in the
projects i've seen people struggle
i can't have people killing themselves
because a father can bring home food to
his children
i can't have a mayor just telling me
well this is the rule and if you don't
like it
i'm gonna get you i'm gonna put you in
jail and if you don't wear the mask
you're gonna be i'm gonna kill you i'm
gonna put you i'm gonna
take away your business i'm gonna shut
you down and if you don't like it you
hear what the governor said
you don't like it too bad what do you
mean you don't like it too bad
i don't care what you say mr governor
you work for me
just like the parks i got them all open
and finally the mayor gave up
he gave up all the parks we started
cleaning our own parks and
finally finally they came out that the
parks could be open now with covey they
still haven't closed the parks and my f
worst thing possible to you tim they're
doing our covet testing in the parks
here's my stupid question and i said it
to you before how do you have a covert
testing with a coveted patient coming
into a park with little children
does that make sense to you just that
alone tells me that he's an
i have to say thank you i love you tim
you're so delicious i love you
i'm going to give you a big hug so i
don't like you
i'm joking again you're wonderful i'm
joking
okay okay this is a joke wow you too
seriously
very serious i was reading i think i was
reading a lawsuit and they said that
one of the points brought up is that
mayor de blasio says look we got all
these hot spots
all these red zones we got to shut them
down
and then someone brought up yeah but out
of all of the red zones the only ones
who shut down were the jewish
neighborhoods
right it's kind of obvious the idiot uh
gave testing in our neighborhood and i
have it on video first they came in they
do all the news conferences in city hall
all of a sudden one day they showed up
in my neighborhood in a park
and they did it right before jewish
hollywood everybody's cooking and
cleaning and running around with their
children getting their houses
ready they came to do a press conference
right before the holiday of course i
caught them
and i wouldn't let that idiot mitch katz
talk i just for 19 minutes screamed and
hollered and told him
how do you show up here with no
paperwork talking blindly i mean
i barely i when i do my work during the
day i need 20 pieces of documents i need
to
do research so much going on and this
guy walks and it starts quoting numbers
that are impossible
and i for 90 minutes i kept screaming
and hollering at me and he left
and they got upset with me and the may
of course sent a message to his liaison
we're going to get you
i said be my guest i live at 43 16 17th
avenue hello world
come on over come down that's how they
found me by the way they none of my
police officers wanted to arrest me
so they had to send two warrant officers
from the bronx wait a minute
four detectives seven cop cars el chapo
didn't have so many people
i am the man then they locked me in my
handcuffs for four
hours they wouldn't take me to the
precinct they took me straight to
central booking
left me in a car four hours handcuffed
making me suffer until i finally said
you know what i'm going to take a leak
right here in the car am i allowed to
say that
yeah okay so then where are you you
pissed in the cabin
i was going to do a choice i have no
problem they took me inside
and then when i got into the jail cells
everybody wanted me into their jail cell
they actually lost my fingerprints twice
do you believe this
i missed the night judge and they kept
me there for 24 hours listen to me man
i've slept in my car sleeping on a dirty
and there's no social distancing in the
police in the
in the jails no masks guys are there for
three days without showers
dirty filthy i'm helping a few of them
now that i met there
i'm telling you so he doesn't keep his
own rules on social distance of course
we're going to have
diseases passed over there these people
are incompetent
losers so i asked him i said make me
deputy mayor i'll work with the city
i'll show you what i can do in three
weeks give me a shot
but no we're going to keep the school so
then he started closing all the
schoolyards
finally i had a fight with that and we
got our schoolyards open some of them
because some of the superintendents
listened to me
but this guy is just foolish and then i
told my store owners no no
keep them open just for your knowledge
right before i was arrested
i was asked to join a 40 zoom conference
call i'm just a regular guy community
activist fighting for my community
they had cops on there local activists
leaders
rabbis politicians and they all agreed
that for the last jewish holiday which
was simchas torah which
after my two protests they asked me
don't do another protest
we want to keep the community calm
because there was a fight whatever with
me and i was
being taunting the mayor and the
governor heshi
chill and so they put me on this earth
and the commission of the police was on
the
conference call and they all our leaders
said you know what
for the holiday we're going to keep our
synagogues closed and each one kept
saying we're
parrots and knocking their communities
we have different communities this far
the community the syrian community
different communities different leaders
and you know i have my own imam i
tell you that i have my own pastor
because i have muslim girl that came
through my house
i have no problem i i work with all
different communities i am
a man that believes that this is a great
country my father was in the holocaust
survived it came through
fires of hell you're telling me that i'm
not gonna continue fighting for this
great country
i was born here bred here fought my way
all the way back
no no nobody's taking nothing for me and
i'm not bragging here i'm nobody special
but
i was on the phone and they're all
agreeing to this and i was one of the
last speakers
and the commissioner says well we're
going to not enforce the rule and i told
the commissioner
right there i got on the phone i said
you're we have a court order telling you
that you can't do what you're doing
the executive order he just made mr
cuomo is trying to override a court
order
he can't do this so here's the deal you
have no right to enforce it
if you do we're not going to listen to
you so if you come in your guns with
your synagogues we're not going to let
you in
you need a warrant and and and the
commissioner says you can't talk to me
like that i said sure i can't i'm
telling you now
that you will not come into my
neighborhood on the holidays
wow and every synagogue was open in my
community
every place was every play group was
open okay our stores were closed anyways
due to the holiday we went out we can't
drive around
and i was driving around and the police
were very good about it our local cops
know us they love us they work with us
but again when the hierarchy wants to
boss you around they do it
my boys told me they didn't want to
arrest me that's why you had to send
people from other
districts i was going to resist i was
going to fight the cops i'm a big guy
so they beat me up by a little bloody
would have been good for the campaign
you know what i mean a little blood look
what the guy did
but at the end i decided you know what
i'm going to be a man i'm gonna take it
in but you know i i wasn't gonna let
them push me around i
walked myself around and i was gonna
turn myself in anyways
that was the funny part the next morning
i was gonna turn myself in but the mayor
just couldn't take it
that i was getting so much uh a
publicity my children out there i want
you to hear me
okay this is america you are free
you are free i am free we
the people i'm not gonna preach to you
the constitution or anything you're not
taking my rights
you're not coming into my home you're
not locking my doors
i don't want to take a vaccine i won't
take it yeah take it i'm not telling you
not to wear a mask when you're going to
a store
you want to go into somebody's store he
tells you to wear a mask wear mask
that's it it's your right walk on the
street leave me alone and and and the
numbers are out there
you don't have to wear a mask outside
you know the trains people are touching
everything
you can't keep it that clean we have the
restaurants open you know these outside
restaurants in new york
they're nicer than the indoor
restaurants yeah they call it uh eating
out
eating outside where you can eat inside
so long as the inside is outside of the
original inside it's meaningless this
guy's whacked and i
and i've kept restaurants open and i'm
telling him to fight but he's shutting
my people down
he's putting people out of business and
i'm fighting them back and he's giving
us fines and he's just for your
knowledge
he has health department inspectors
doing building inspections
building inspectors and parole officers
doing health inspections these guys are
not qualified he takes people with no
badges
or people with guns listen to this tim
people with gotten sheriffs because our
police won't do it
climbing into little girl schools with
guns climbing through the window or
taking pictures peeping into windows
are you crazy really mr mayor you but
let me tell you is that cop
crazy it's like he's he's crazy it's
sheriff crazy not my cops cops and all
these things but i want you to know what
happened over the weekend i would i want
you to enjoy this
uh 17 shootings four murders
i don't want to tell you that i even had
a rape last sunday thank god we came
back in my building
because they they see the buildings
really empty just that sunday me and my
partner were there
thank god we saw in the camera we ran
out they tried to rape a young muslim
girl 14 year old
we stopped it we chased it we gave the
cops pictures
two days later we caught the guy because
we know our neighborhood
this is what he allows my neighborhood
is patrolled nothing is boarded up
downtown brooklyn 10 minutes away from
me
this is the fancy rich people i'm not
talking a co-op there a one-bedroom
studio can go for a million dollars
and that's cheap i'm talking that's for
the poor people
those people are boarding up their
windows they're breaking into banks
they're ripping off telling machines
because they can't be watched and this
guy is letting him get away with it but
you know what he's busy with
that we have to close our stores close
our schools and wear masks and come
after the jews because we're quiet we're
wussies well you know what
no more my movement has started it
spread it spread around my city
it's spread to other cities like buffalo
it's spreading upstate
we're standing up even the sheriff's
upstate are you crazy you're going to
enforce thanksgiving i can only have 10
people
would you like to know how many people i
had thanksgiving in my house yeah how
many
50. i had two extra seats for cuomo and
de blasio
just in case they needed a meal i'm just
telling you and hanukkah is coming
i'm trying to get a hundred people in
there just for your knowledge
10 people what are we taught i just uh i
can't say [ __ ]
no no you actually youtube goes nuts
when you yeah yeah they don't like it
yeah wow youtube youtube has gone crazy
i guess i'm not getting elected
so so heshitisla.com everybody i need 25
donations from all your people i
guarantee to be what do you do with the
money
so let me tell you what i'm doing i
don't need a salary man i don't need
matching funds
i want to win with no questions asked
i'm not going in with 700 800 signatures
i'm going in there with 10 000. there
will be no doubt
i will go in there i'm going in there
with five new councilmen that i know
that are going to work with me
i have one that's going to be incumbent
from my neighborhood i have three
republicans that are worthless in
brooklyn in new york city everybody has
to run as a democrat i know people
you're upset i'm running as a democrat
well my most of my people go blind
i can be republican but i have to run on
the democratic ticket or i won't get
nothing done
so i want to go in there i want to win
i'm going to go there and
and campaign to my local community put
out the posters i'm gonna have to do a
lot of stuff i need pollsters i need
people getting signatures from me
i need people running from door to door
for me i need an office staff
elections cost money to run and i need
250 grand to run it but i'm gonna i'm
trying to raise the money and i don't
need a lot of money from people i need
twenty five fifty dollars from you guys
send it in tashitishla.com you know why
because i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna
make a change and if it starts here
it's gonna start everywhere and when i
get rid of this mayor and when i change
my city council it's called a clean
sweep
i know i've been doing it from the
outside for all these years it's time
for me to pick up
shut up or s or or stand up and i'm
going to stand up
if something doesn't change in new york
that city is going to be destroyed
completely destroyed now my son
you're this right now sure well go down
fifth avenue
you it's a shame you have windows that
are boarded up you can't look in macy's
had to board up their windows
restaurants are out of business i've i
have i have
people that can't pay their rent but we
raised our taxes that if you pay your
taxes rate is an 18
penalty do you believe it i can't
collect rent i can't pay rent
but if i don't pay my taxes on time i
have to pay an 18 fine
that's what they do just by the way all
fines in the city of new york have just
tripled
and tripled yeah from uh from a thousand
dollars to three thousand from five
thousand
again i don't even know how that law
passed he was just able to do without
permission
and and and i want you to tell you the
best part we now have a new rule in new
york city we're allowed to rat on you
that means if you're driving down the
block tim and you double park and i see
you double parked i take a picture of
your car
you now get instead of 115 ticket a
hundred and seventy five dollar ticket i
send it over to
the city and i get twenty five percent i
don't need to work
oh yeah tim you and me let's just drive
around they're gonna pay
you to snitch on your neighbors so you
don't believe me about this new law i'm
sure you don't believe me
so we have something that passed
recently called the idling law
that tim when you drive your car and you
pull over and you stop and you're
waiting for me to come out of the store
if you idle for more than three minutes
and i videotape you thousand dollar fine
whoa yeah and it's amazing in fact
matter of fact billy idol gets on
tv i don't know if you like him but i
don't like him anymore
i used to like him as a kid he gets on
he says don't
listen to the idling law come on man
he's making 311 was there to help the
community to
to call to see if there was complaints
on the streets now 3-1-1 is made
just to call on your neighbor they come
down the complaint doesn't exist
but the inspector always finds something
i know this is what i do for a living i
fight the inspectors i help people
get their houses back he just comes in
they find something else to punish you
shut down your job and don't think islam
of these inspectors they they're they're
prejudiced as well i
i work with them i take off my yamaku
when i work down i'm embarrassed to tell
you that i can't tell them i'm a jew
even though they figured it out by now
but some of them don't understand it and
i and i just have to listen to their
prejudice
their filth when they make fun of the
muslims or the asians or the or the
jewish or the black people they
themselves do it
and i stand there and i take it why
because i have to defend my people
whatever it takes for my people to win
and yes my de blasio hates us i think i
have to i have to correct you on
something
you said that they were incompetent well
hold on uh
i would say first you are partly correct
but when you say that everything they're
doing is due to incompetence
i think you're doing it i think it's on
purpose but when when we know there are
more red zones than just the jewish
parks but they go after the jewish parks
when you're telling me that they're now
incentivizing people to take photos and
snitch on their neighbors
they're shutting down the businesses in
defiance of the science in defiance of
the
the world health organization straight
up said last resort don't do it if you
can avoid it they're like nah we're
gonna do it anyway
cdc said don't shut down the schools he
went i'm gonna do it anyway
they're doing it on purpose and
everything they're doing has the impact
of
destroying the economy of new york city
they're burning it to the ground
wow that but you want to go a step
further not did i understand it at all
but when i did the 2000 tests in my
community and we did it in a safe clean
environment
we went to the governor mayor look we
did the right tests the 24-hour tests
and what happened yellow zone but my
neighborhood the next door neighborhood
that somehow the city you know they get
they get money for
everybody who does testing these private
organizations there's always somebody
making money on it
200 300 400 how to do tests on the
street which i have no idea
again the neighborhood next to us red
which if you would have listened to me i
would have shown you how to do the
testing
i told you the story about the lady in
the hospital she had a baby they
wouldn't let her out she said chad
covert
i came walking in there with testing and
i showed them they're lying
and on saturday on the sabbath we picked
up and we left with the baby oh no
you're not stopping us look you lied
i had one lady that was uh went for
operation wanted to see her child's
wedding three days later they gave her a
cover test
positive she called me up i said come on
guys really
how is she positive she's in the
hospital she's all better she's positive
i said let's give her a 24-hour test
since these pcr tests are wrong anyways
he says no okay finally after a big
fight we gave her the 24 hour test two
three hours later
no no three hours later he came back and
said positive i said how can you give me
a 24-hour test three hours later
i went in with my people we did the
testing we released
my city is lost i you want me to give
you an answer on corruption you want me
to tell you that
the election was fraudulent there's
something wrong here
and and and the people in the in in the
hierarchy think that they own us
stop it i'm not gonna let them own me
i'm gonna fight back
my my community is fighting back we're
standing up a lot of them are scared to
lose the big bucks
i know i know it's a shame especially
for special needs children
i know for the welfare i know for the
meals on wheels i know we have a lot of
programs
out there but you know what the jewish
community got 20 000
last year for postpartum depression it's
a very bad issue in my community
the neighborhood over that's not jewish
got 43 million dollars
we have a 90 billion dollar budget
that's 9 billion dollars in the whole
now normally when you're in the hole you
got to lay off some of your workers
so he laid off the whole new york city
right none of us are allowed to go to
work
all 337 000 employees of new york city
were working throughout the entire
covert
300 all you had to do was lay off maybe
about one quarter of them
to save on your budget never did it why
because something is wrong here he kept
collecting he keeps finding so he made
up for the tourism problem because he
only gets like eight or ten percent of
that
to with the fines that's what he did the
man is an incompetent he doesn't know
how to run the city i am a competency
i i got to tell you it sounds like i
believe he's incompetent
but come on that's on purpose huh he
found a way because our house we took
our
community that was it fires you know the
bronx in the 70s was all burnt down
brooklyn also was in the in the late
1800s
under siege and we have built fort
brick by brick house by house fought
legalized went through every attorney
general found every law to rebuild a
community
we have 200 000 people do you know how
many drug centers we have one
two youth centers we have drug problems
we have kids in it with issues
again they won't give us the money for
it so we have to do it ourselves
the man only cares about himself i'm
sorry no no no no
you're uh you're running as a democrat
but i remember seeing these protests and
i remember seeing
a bunch of people carrying big old trump
flags we love mystery
his policies are correct he's done a
great job with the economy
i am a man for trump again in new york
city we have a problem
we are a blue state there's nothing to
question people
i saw it but you know when i went i when
my my mother passed away three years ago
and uh people came to my house to to you
know while i was mourning because i go
to all the homes i go visit a lot of
people
and i had hundreds of people come to say
it was so nice of them that's why i l
i love my community and and they were
just good to me and where i raised my
children they all came to wish me well
and people said these two guys are
running for councilman who are
incompetent one cheated to get in again
he was able to get himself on the ballot
by cheating
and he got the democratic nobody knew
this guy
and the next guy got an independent and
i with three weeks to go with fifteen
thousand dollars i ran
as an independent now i won them in the
debate i was great
but the point is people went to the
polls blindly and just clicked democrat
democrat democrat the guy won
and the last four years i don't want to
knock him he's i like him don't get me
wrong he's a nice boy
again nothing has been done hasn't stood
up when i started cutting the locks for
the parks they showed up
hi ashley we're here to help you where
are you one day and then they disappear
again
they're hiding in their basements
they're passing laws legislation
crying about budgets which they've never
done a budget before in their life
you know i didn't take any ppe money
when my when we were doing covert i kept
every one of my workers working
home running around because we were a
lot of my people were essential
and i kept working them and were paying
him and trust me it hurt us because we
tried to have a cushion in the business
we work on it we're worried for busy
days my wife and me
know that bad days are coming and we've
used it mr may de blasio is spoiled he
has no idea so when i keep saying
incompetent
forget that what he's after to get us of
course a bigot
wants to come after the easy prey of
course he wants to go after
the poor black family that can't stand
up for themselves and then
there's a lot of black people that could
stand up and take advantage of the
situation
we have the same thing in the jewish
community you know we have guys buying
up
poor people's houses and then after he
buys up the whole community he says oh
let's move to jersey
let's all go to israel no no i'm here
i'm here to stay
i don't care what you've abused us
there's always somebody in every
community
it still sounds like the jails too are
getting abused people are getting
stuffed in a cell with no
proper you know i go through this i go
to jail every two weeks to visit people
and i see the the the the way they abuse
them
and you're right some of you gonna say
well they deserve it they don't deserve
it
you know i have people coming home from
i'm into prison reform and people come
home
you think they can be better in one day
they've served seven years three years
nine months in jail people lose focus
i'm there
to try to help them to guide them i'm
not their boss don't get it out of their
way i'm not
i know they're going to cause some
issues i'm there to help them if they
want help
so in response to stories about the
jails being overcrowded people getting
sick
they started just cutting people loose
and then we started seeing a bunch of
people getting cut loose committing
crimes
yeah so that was a that was a big
complaint from conservatives i should
say
and many of them didn't live in new york
but they were pointing to new york
saying how insane is it
that you're going to let these people go
but then i'm my position is like first
of all
if somebody isn't convicted and they're
in jail because they just got charged
they may be innocent
then i don't think we can stuff them
into you know a disease-written
shoulder-to-shoulder you know cell so
what do you do do you do you know so new
york
uh passed that bail reform law right
correct cashless bail
but there's so much that we could do
there's so many ideas on
uh wearing uh um a device on your leg um
having people it's not just bail having
people take responsibility for you
i'm not asking for bail the parole
officers are busy watching our stores
and giving us violations
when they should be watching these guys
who were letting out on bail or nobel
you know
they were even considering and giving me
bail for a riot that never happened
by the way my riot never happened this
guy i'm not allowed to talk really about
it my lawyers are going to kill me
not that i care because i never listen
to lawyers lawyers are all stupid
yeah we need them they are guys i'm more
smarter than them
but always never trust your lawyer
listen to me guys
you are the boss you watch them yeah
they know the law they know the
paperwork you do your research today
with the internet you can do it
be your own boss they are your employee
some of these lawyers again think
they're smarter than you i don't care
what they charge
so i know this guy woke me up three
o'clock in the morning i was pissed
and he came to he came to the first
protest and the second protest wasn't
set up by me
the cops themselves called me in the
middle of the night
said heshi the kids are burning masks
masks we didn't make no big fights it
was put out with a fire extinguisher
i should come help us i said but i'm
home in bed my wife is gonna kill me get
over here as she so i got out of bed i
came there i broke up the protest
and i told everybody go home and nobody
wanted to go so the cops said if you
all go home we'll allow you to come back
tomorrow for two hours with music
and you can have like a dancing holiday
protest and i got on the microphone the
police microphone
and i told everybody and everybody went
home the next day this guy who was at
the first protest
again he woke me up in the middle of the
night telling me you're a bad man called
me some bad name and i went over to him
in the street like i would see you tim
if you went and started you know waking
me up a little night come over you tim
you're you're a bad man
you're crazy and of course whenever
there's a fight a lot of people came
around and just saw my little argument
and the cops were all stationed i had
them stationed beautifully all around
the two black area
two minutes later they came and whisked
them off his brother-in-law was there
protecting him
nothing happened what did i do threat
entrapment and
inciting a riot why do i nobody was
arrested that night
nothing was burned down no windows were
broken nothing happened you mean
incitement
right incitement to right nobody was
arrested even the cops are laughing that
nothing happened
nobody was arrested and all of a sudden
they come three days later after i talk
to the police commissioner they come and
ask me
why mayor de blasio wanted to show that
he's the boss you know what he's not the
boss
i'm my own boss people your own boss
stand up
don't be scared if you're scared come to
a guy come to an activist
i am not scared i fight for you know my
father told me something i'm sure you
heard this
before he passed away i was a little boy
and he told me he says has she there's
two things in life you can do that's it
that's all he told me
you can do something or you can do
nothing that's it
that's your whole that's my philosophy
i'm never gonna do nothing my sons
i'm never gonna do it i'm always gonna
be there to do something i'm always
going to be
to the rest of my life as much as to my
last dying breath
i know some of you guys believe in god
you don't believe in god when i stand
before the holy maker
i'm going to give him an answer i'm
going to tell him what i did i screwed
up
don't get me wrong me and linda fight
every day she's usually wrong
but i don't laugh to him she is she
look at lydia you'll be quiet all your
women are against us i don't like
linda you're right i love you baby
you're so gorgeous
31 years she's tortured me i the words
anyways
i want you to know this is what we do
it's a battle each day
and my woman is with me and i'm so proud
of her for allowing me
to stand up even though we discussed me
and linda discussed this was the year
that i was gonna retire we were gonna we
put away a little bit of money we were
gonna go into the sun and flowers i was
gonna watch my tv
on the beach all day long and make fun
of all you people
but it came up that we can't we can't
let our children our grandchildren our
foster children you know some of the
foster children we had you know i was a
little tough on you know
i'm a big fat guy so i threatened to put
them in the basement naked you know
it's a joke it's a joke stop it i'm
laughing i know yeah
look at it he has something in his hands
he's gonna throw it at me
i was a little tough linda was always
good loving mother and you know what
they call it to this day and sometimes i
i'm so proud when they call in they
speak to her
and i laugh behind the scenes how hard
we worked on that and
and linda giggles even though of all
those no terrible days that we had with
them
i'm proud of her and i'm proud that
she's my woman and she stood by me
you know you've got to be there
everybody's got their quirks everybody's
got their
their crazy uh you know sicknesses in
them again like drugs i'm against drugs
i don't care about marijuana being
approved i don't care what your audience
says because i know little kids have it
i've been against drugs all my life
there are ways that you can do it in
your home not for me
never for me i'm here to fight for my
children i'm here to fight for the next
generation
i'm here to fight for my neighbor i'm
here to fight for my senior citizens
this is what i do from morning to late
at night
and never will i stop trust me never you
just had one of the biggest possible
victories you could have when the
supreme court ruled that
you guys can keep your places of worship
open not just the jewish community but
all the religious communities are now
allowed to well they were always allowed
to right and cuomo
was directly in violation of the
constitution and he made an executive
audit now
after we won the court cases oh the
executive order expired but here's my
problem he's going to create a new
executive order december 1st to override
this
supreme court order and he's going to
win and here's the problem he can say
whatever i do
i am the boss mr cuomo i i can't
threaten to beat you up because i'll get
in trouble with tim and i'll get in
trouble with the cops
but if you ever want to take off the
governor title pop over to beau park
brooklyn pop up to my third floor
let's go man-to-man i know you can kick
my butt but when i'm done with you baby
you'll be crying too sanction your
sanction official
not mike dyson it's going to be from
benson street for the kids he's a big
tough guy i know he'll beat me up but i
just want him to feel the pain
i want him to see my neighbor he he's
scared to come town neighborhood he's
scared the man
is scared to come and here's the big
thing i i'm i'm telling you that i have
my wedding halls open
i have all of them open we're hiding
we're doing it in sneaky but i'm going
to weddings one month i went to 17
weddings
i have little children in schools in the
dark i promise you in the dark
learning because they're scared of the
sheriffs coming in to shut them down
special needs mothers that are having
nervous breakdowns i had a lady commit
suicide two and a half weeks ago
she couldn't take it she couldn't take
it you how do you have an autistic child
you think you don't need a break you
think you don't have a special needs
child
that needs daily care to go to the thing
the kid himself is gonna have a nervous
breakdown
we had one kid that we had to take him
three times to the hospital
with all the problems we have in the
world and you're just making it worse
because you think you're saving lives
more dying because of him
he's lying he has he's a fool and i'm
telling you i'm so pissed i'll go back
to jail whatever it takes to protect my
fellow man and it's not for new york
it's
all first of all i'll be representing
all of new york city even though i'll be
elected by my community
but i'll be representing the country i
want the people to know
stand up don't be scared of that idiot
governor in los angeles who himself had
a party
the governor of new jersey twice the
governor of new jersey goes out to
dinner with the family
no problem and everybody's screaming at
him and the best part is new york city
they had a birthday party a birthday
party for somebody
with 20 30 of the politicians and we
said hey we caught you and they said oh
there's only six of us there
we said are you crazy look around here
are pictures we see 20 30 of you
oh they were coming and going rules
rules for thee but not for me
exactly that's tyranny right so i want
you to know
i am not scared of him if you're scared
of him coming i will be your shield
new york city we're going to stand up
we're going to fight back i want the
rest of the country to fight back
don't be scared what can they do to you
give you a ticket
put you in jail for a day most likely
the little towns to sheriff are you
neighbors
and if you have some kind of a bully
there let's let's call him out let's
call somebody from other towns
i'm getting you know antifa threatening
me i don't know if you know who they are
oh of course
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait hold on hold on antifa threatened
yeah they did it through instagram they
sent some message we're gonna come get
you
and who else came after me wait wait
wait wait hold hold on hold on
you're you're challenging authoritarian
government edict
that's our some of it uh with the
supreme court ruling been proven to be a
violation of your rights
and the anti-fascists are threatening
you
because again they're allowed to protest
we can't and again i'm for trump and
they're for biden whatever so they
threatened me and there was one more
organization to threaten me
i forgot what it was and i posted it all
over the place and i said i'm not scared
of the may i'm not scared of antifa
come to my house again i'm not scared of
you what can you do to me you got one
go ahead you got one down i'm not that
important and then i got so much love
from nevada
from idaho from jersey from california
we're going to come protect you
i had a group of guys that just said
we're coming to your house now history
to watch you i i i
have police officers that came to my
house and asked me to sign an autograph
for their mother they were embarrassed
that i was arrested their mother
screamed at them i
am a guy that is just my neighbor and i
know
that that suffering we do suffer enough
we all have issues in our families we
all have problems
you know my sister is down syndrome and
i've been taking care of her
for the last 43 years since my father
passed away
and she's beautiful she prays for me
every day because she says i'm going to
hell i'm no good
and she has more money than me by the
way all women have more money than me
what the hell's wrong with me 10 you
must not be working hard i'm not working
hard
i'm not a good man but my show is not
doing well either
i'm joking with you but you know guys
heshitishla.com i'm desperate right now
i'm dead meat
but i'm telling you the love of your
fellow man
is more important than anything and i
know some of you gonna say i'm preaching
this is what i've done for 30 years
whether you like it or not whether you
want to knock me or not people are not
telling me oh hell [ __ ] we saw you
cheating on your wife my wife was
sitting in the car when you heard the
message
you're doing drugs again you can't catch
me on anything because i know who i
am i'm not gonna lie to you you want me
to wear my suit and tie
you want me to sand straight you know
they call me into the office of the
politicians
i walk around my shirt on top my jacket
i'm wearing a suit and tie for you tim i
thought you were gonna
dress up tonight i know you know i know
anyways and my wife bought this ugly tie
i'm gonna burn it on the way out
no it doesn't either i hate you ann you
look great it was bad
she paid 55 bucks is she crazy
but i want you to know that this is what
i do and they
sat me down you're gonna wear a suit and
tar you're gonna follow the rules you're
gonna talk normal listen to me
this is who i am if the people of my
community want to elect me
you elect me who i am i will fight for
you who i am
when you know on i was telling you
before on the city council we have a
channel called the city council channel
very boring they scratch their behinds
they pick the nose you want to die at
the end of the four hours really you
actually want to cut your wrists
when i get it to city council everybody
tune in watch baby
here comes round two i'm gonna blow the
city council that's gonna be the number
one show on town
i'm gonna make them miserable i'm not
gonna let them pass illegal laws you
know they read one
one one paragraph blurbs and they vote
on a bill
which is 40 50 pages long 30 of them a
month
you know what this is for too long the
american people have kind of just sat
back and hit the d button or the r
button or checked d or checked r
and you end up with a bunch of
politicians who just want the job but
don't want to do it
so they get elected because well they're
probably not good at anything else
so hey convince some people to vote for
you you get a salary you get a job you
can have power you can you know
shake hands kiss babies and all that
stuff and then go and sit down and do
nothing
and as as long as nothing was happening
no one cared and everything moved along
now that we're actually facing a real
crisis
and these uh these mayors these
governors
are well i'm gonna say it i think andrew
cuomo murdered six thousand five hundred
people this is a story from propublica
he he ordered six coveted patients into
nursing homes
and this was back several months ago
propublica reported on this
they said as around 6 500 or so seniors
died of kovid because of andrew cuomo
and he's not the only governor that did
it
so you've got these people doing this
outright insane
i mean stupidity it's it's he killed
these people
so i want to tell you most of these
nursing homes get money from the
government
so they were willing to take these
patients back and i screamed at a lot of
them i even have
relatives in the business and he says
well we're understaffed i said if you're
under staff then shut down the business
or get more people
it's not only for the profit lives are
not profitable
so there was one jewish boy had a
nursing home in jersey
and he told the governor drop dead i'm
not taking the people back
i don't care about you we're going to
find you we're going to close you down
he says no problem i'm not going to let
people die in my place
he was one of the only ones that had
nobody die in his nursing home
governor cuomo we had 1400 people die in
my hospital
my hospital is made you go there you're
sick you get some medicine you go home
it's not a place to be incubated or be
taken you know forever to get better
these guys are not trained remember some
of them are residents they're beginning
nurses i go there i see it you can't
overcrowd them they're not competent as
it is sometimes
they're overloaded with nothing you're
shoving them in there they don't know
what they're doing
people for two days didn't have water i
had a guy in my office crying at his
father they wouldn't let you know they
don't let us visit the nursing home
still to this day but the hospitals
let's go there was one guy in the
hospital when they wouldn't let him in
there
for two days with no food or water the
man was crying finally he was able to
get his phone and he cried to his son
please come in there they took away his
phone we found the phone in jersey and
he was died the next day
they said covered when we knew that it
was hunger and thirst and this is a true
story there's nothing you can do because
i have the boy you came to the protest
with me to the hospital
they killed his father and it's not one
i have many stories like this one after
the next after the next
the mayor and governor are two we have
so many politicians i'm not talking one
we have 51 councilman 300 assemblymen
500 state senators and i'll go down the
list of how many community board leaders
and so on and nobody's standing up to
these two winners
nobody's standing up and saying stop mr
governor mayor his liaisons are walking
around threatening us you know the mayor
said
no funerals and when when people die no
mornings
he went to the big rabbi who he tried to
shut down the big rabbi's wedding
he went to them when the rabbi died one
of their brothers died he went to the
morning there was no social distancing
there
you can't go into somebody else's house
when this covered especially if somebody
just died in the house
again he broke his own law and of course
his liaison which is one of my people
i'm ashamed to tell you
the to the jewish liaison to the
community is kissing the mayor's behind
and he's he's giving up his people so he
can get a salary my councilman get a
hundred eighty thousand dollar salary
for each committee they sit on they get
thirty to forty thousand dollars they
sit on seven committees now forget you
have to do an eight hour day plus you
have to do seven committees
plus you have to run around meet people
plus you have to collect money
these guys seem to be able to pass laws
make all this money they get 350 380 000
by the end of the year they get a
million one for office expenses
a million five to give out to their
favorite charities or donations
that means ian if you have like a little
sweater company and you're giving to the
poor people some of the sweaters
we'll give you twenty thousand dollars
that's how it works now after all that
they still get another sixty nine
dollars a day for lunch money or stipp
and i don't even know what that is
you know and this keeps going and going
so we'll we'll down 150 million dollars
before we blink
just with the 51 counseling forget the
community boys then you have
commissioners
of five different agencies department of
buildings department of health i'm going
to go through 312 of them i'm not
department of sanitation department of
finance and of course the
hpd department each one has
commissioners in every bow
each one has chiefs if one have
duplicate jobs and then you have all
your inspectors
combine them work them up we can save a
billion dollars just in that money
idiots and each each agency fights with
each agency
i know but each agency fights with each
agency to put stuff through a department
of buildings
you have to go through the department of
health then you have to go through the
department of finance and each one can
take three to four to five months
do you know how long it takes to get a
set of plans approved today in new york
city
about six to eight months so you're
paying mortgage on your house
you can't walk kick downs because if you
do any work you get a 10 15 000
penalty plus they don't let you if you
didn't work without a house to get
another permit for another year
you're being punished we're like little
kids we get punished and it just gets
worse and worse then when you have to
all your paperwork
now you have to go to the parks
department to get a tree planted in
front of your house
which they only plant twice a year so
now you can't even move into your house
till you get a stupid tree
and here's the best part you paid all
your fines you did everything correctly
you now have to verify
the last thing on your list is to verify
your address it's called topo
a one small agency that cost you a
hundred bucks they've been closed for
the last eight months
so you can't get your dress verification
you're screwed so
so uh and this is just one little bit of
red tape
i'm sorry i've seen a bunch of videos
from you know these like leftists on
twitter
where they walk around a wealthy area
showing the ice cream shops and then say
new york is totally fine everything's
normal stop watching fox news
i you know i i walk around new york city
i'm the guy in the street
i'm gonna tell you of of of empty stores
of closed doors
of people getting fined of of houses
that are sitting
vacant for not months for years
people can't move into their own homes
that they work so hard to renovate or
build
uh they're getting fake stop work orders
you know what a stop work order is the
inspector comes in well you built an
extra wall you didn't follow the plan
you're not conforming stop work order
just like that and nobody can work or
we're vacating you because your
grandmother is living down in the
basement
when you're only allowed to have a couch
and a tv but you put a bed down there
it's illegal
vacate your house it sounds like they're
destroying new york on purpose i mean i
said it before
but all of these stories everything i've
seen
when you look at the riots it happened
in june and then you see
the uh the i believe it was the
assistant district attorney started
cutting loose the lower level
you know misdemeanor charges they've
done this all over it it feels like
you've got you know what let me let me
start over
i think earlier this year we had a very
serious problem we had we had uh a
couple hospitals in new york had
that were overflowing they brought in
the trucks we we didn't see the javits
center completely full but there are
people
you know in there i think we completely
panicked
we overreacted but but initially
i'm not too upset that we over
overreacted in the beginning because we
did have a very serious problem spike
and a lot of deaths
now it seems like something's different
they're saying hospitalizations are up
coveted cases are up and the amount of
deaths are going up
and it feels like everything they did
early on didn't work
they're just going to do the same thing
over again but what i really think
is that they're exploiting it you've got
politicians who've realized they can use
it
to gain whatever they want because we
run the risk of getting banned on
youtube simply
simply by questioning or talking about
it or bringing these things up
i got a story here it's from john
hopkins university published a study
the researcher compared the previous
years the total
the average deaths in the u.s and found
that the average deaths this year
are almost no different the interesting
thing though is that
heart disease deaths were way down and
kova deaths were way up
and they concluded in this uh article
that they believe that kova deaths were
being over exaggerated their words
i could get banned for just bringing the
story up the story gets deleted
terrible without without notice now if
you bring the story up they say it's
fake news
the researcher stands by it saying no i
pulled the publicly available research
compared the date the the information
and they say
it's fake news if you bring that up
you're right and i want you to know if
you would look at last year's death
though and you don't have to check with
me you don't have to believe me
you can go to the cdc or to the health
department january
february this year and last year were
identical deaths
throughout you get it to the funeral
piles there's a special website for it
correct march april may and june we went
up 25
000 uh additional deaths in new york
city again panic
uh fake numbers whatever it is but yeah
25 000 more during
the uh compared to the year before july
august september october
have matched last year now i don't know
how you're telling me there's more cover
death
but the same death rate is now the same
as last year's
debt certificates remember each death
certificate is numbered so you can't
trick the city
so the numbers are the same i don't know
where spike second wave was supposed to
hit us in july
second wave august september october
it's november so far no second wave
one out of every three 000 people that
die from covet
is under the age of 65. most of them are
above 65 so you have to take care of
your seniors
but we can't take care of our seniors
because we're not making money and they
have nowhere to eat nowhere to go
and if you noticed they're going out
because they have no choice
do you remember when de blasio said he
wanted to buy up the buildings yeah
so they they they force everything to
shut down they get rid of tourists they
destroy the economy and then property
value tanks because people are evicted
and kicked out
bill de blasio says you know i think
we'll buy them and turn them into buy
them we can take them
take them yeah yeah you know he wants to
distribute the wealth
we've been wealthy too long so it's now
time to share
this is what he says you hear it you
don't have to listen to me listen to his
news conference
we have to take the wealth we've been
wealthy for the last 40 years it's time
that we equal everything out take the
wealth from the wealthy and give it
to other people is he really is he
really normal mentally ill i mean
there's something wrong with him you
just can't do it well i mean he can be a
communist doesn't mean he's mentally ill
i think that's mentally ill but
everybody in the chat is going to say
yes
yes but he thinks he can take away our
properties
he thinks we're all going to leave and
and just do whatever he wants i'm not
going to let him do it
i'm standing yes i'm the one guy right
now standing in his way
and i'm gonna get to city council i'm
hoping he'll be gone i know he'll be
gone
i'm gonna clean sweep the city council
with a bunch of good people and if not
you're gonna see me stop them i'm gonna
filibuster them i'm not gonna let them
get away with it
you know i don't know if you like aoc or
not
another witch not a big fan right so she
we had amazon
came into new york city promised us 25
billion dollars listen to me people
there's more actually
over 10 years right now right but also
you keep forgetting
the housing that was going to get built
around there another 10 billion dollars
the trickle-down jobs 10 billion dollars
the taxes from these people
plus all the new work that would have
come up all
thrown out why because she was in one of
her moods to show it
bill de blasio and governor cuomo
chickened out and they loved the idea
you're talking what we could have done
the housing the jobs that were going to
come in
i i don't know where my politicians are
saying okay if you don't want it in long
island
come to brooklyn we all want it the
trickle-down jobs just in my
neighborhood would have been in the tens
of millions of dollars
cuomo actually ragged on aoc for that
aoc
but he let her get away with it well
yeah so so uh she ended up saying that
she had nothing to do with it it wasn't
even in my district
and she actually was correct it wasn't
an addition no right to open her mouth
but she was leading protest she was one
of the keynote speakers at a protest in
the financial district saying
that amazon shouldn't come in and man i
tell you
she came out and said why are we giving
amazon 3 billion dollars because she
didn't understand that a discount isn't
giving someone money right so so the
controversy here i don't know you you're
i don't know if you're familiar with oh
no tertiary so
so basically free cut when you hear this
so the city said
we're going to give you a tax break if
you build your headquarters here not
money not money not money a tax break
but there would be rebates and grants
and stuff that would come along with it
basically
if you generate 30 billion dollars in
tax revenue for the city over 10 years
we'll cut off 10 of that so she
actually gave an interview where she
said why are we giving them three
billion dollars
i hate that logic and it's not logic by
the way
there was that was there there were some
grants there were some rebates there was
some money that would come from the city
but it was in the event that amazon set
up an hq it was an incentive it was it
was 25 to 40
000 jobs correct and and listen to me 25
to 40 000
new jobs forget all the other outer jobs
all the new houses all the new consumers
everything everything one of the
businesses that's flourishing in this
crisis right now
amazon yeah sorry to interrupt continue
please this would have been
new housing that would that would be
built new maintenance for the housing
there would be a lot more commerce and
economic exchange in these areas
bodegas oh i love you and she she led
protests because it just fit the
narrative big corporation amazon bad and
hey you know what honestly
i'm down with that narrative because
amazon is profiting like crazy while all
the small businesses are being destroyed
and it's people like cuomo and de blasio
a new sum and all these other governors
and people like pelosi
who break the rules destroy the small
businesses for everybody else while the
big box stores and big corporations make
sweet cash
but i understand there's a difference
and sometimes you're going to say
it would be nice if we had 25 to 40 000
new jobs because i don't know the the
mta in new york is collapsing
right the cities are fo the trains are
falling apart they're they i remember
when they said they were gonna shut down
the l train between williamsburg and
manhattan and it caused a panic in the
housing market
and so they need money to fix this stuff
she decides she's going to lead a
protest
once it comes out that she's destroyed
jobs and everyone's mad she goes
that wasn't me i don't live in that
district and all of a sudden it was like
d do you not remember when we were
criticizing you because you led this
protest in the financial district is new
york gonna give amazon 3 billion no no
no no no there was a discount it's a
discount yeah it's like it's like
i mean it's a rebate right if not they
hit them no no threshold they were going
to give them
no there were some rebates there was
some instances where they would provide
cash but it was all contingent upon if
you have a company here
if you have these jobs if you're
generating billions in tax revenue then
we give you money over time
no you pay less in taxes pay less taxes
so we're not giving you anything but
just a discount
yeah it was a 3 billion discount there
was a small amount
that would have been rebates but that's
not negligible i'm just pointing
it's on money already made accrued so
that's not like
right right exactly so so it would be
like the analogy
she claims is that you go to a you know
like a you know i don't know
pizza store pizza restaurant and they
say you know one dollar off pizza
and then she thinks the pizza the guy
the stop hands the customer the dollar
and then he leaves
no it means if you want to buy a large
pizza it's nine dollars instead of ten
dollars
he's not going to give you a dollar and
then you leave dude i think we have a
lot of lazy politicians right now
do nothing dumbbells dude they don't
they don't even read the bills yeah how
can you
i think it should be firstly of that a
policy should not be allowed to vote on
a bill if they don't read it and they
should swear under oath that they read
the thing
i love you know what i you know i i'm
going to like that you know i love that
idea i never even thought it brilliant
swear underwriter you ready that you
read the whole bill and you're on you
don't even have to understand at least
you read it
not one of your work is ready you know
our trains he was saying about the mta
they cleaned the trains at nighttime
getting rid of covert which
the next day the first person that
touches it gets it back do you know how
rat infested the mta is
ratchet i mean just come if you want to
have a good laugh just stand sometimes
okay all over the place now now that uh
the lockdowns have been for for a long
time rats are roaming the streets and
packs
this is the crazy thing with all these
lockdowns there's no more people
dropping food giving food
so it's actually happening in a bunch of
cities all over the world there's one
crazy video where there's baboons
and they're forming street gangs because
there's no tourists would throw them
food right
now there's nobody so when someone drops
you know an ice cream they all start
fighting each other over it in gangs
in new york this is crazy packs of rats
run down the street and they chase
people he's not joking no it's real yeah
yes
because they used to get the scraps
there's so many people everywhere
dropping scraps the rats were fat and
happy
now they're starving and they're
becoming desperate and they'll chase you
like big too yeah but they're packs it's
crazy
and i want to go on another subject with
you guys this is something that really
bothers me we have a homeless issue and
when you were saying about the hotels
before
mayor de blasio spent his wife that's
why i got in trouble i i didn't know
you're allowed not to call a woman
a bad thing uh well you shouldn't call
people names
okay well that's who i am you know what
i mean she stole i mean she lost 1.25
billion dollars i'm going to call her
the name
well so she was part of a committee
which she's not even an elected official
he put him in charge of the mental
health issue 1.25 billion dollars was
lost
disappeared now first of all let me tell
you as a contractor i can build
sixteen hundred homes i can house over
uh time that by eight by the way
i could put eight people in a home i can
do that put them house them
not apartments not little homeless
shelters if you ever go to homeless
shelter they're disgusting
and i've been to many of them to visit
and help them get approved
homes that we can put them in i have 69
000 homeless people on the street
forget about that they're no good
they're bams they're whatever you want
to talk about about them i don't know
why people would even
degrade them some of them are lost you
have twenty thousand of them that are
children
twenty thousand of my homeless kids are
children sleeping on the street
i don't have much money i go on the
street once a week i try to give out two
dollars five dollars i get a lot of
clothing donations
a lot of people get it but my friends
give me good stuff some nice leftover
jacket
or stuff for the kids and i give it out
wherever i could and on friday i do my
two
three hours and they're so happy and
when mary de blasio took them off the
street and put them in a hotel
you know what i mean and now since he
says covet is restricted right we all
have to be in their homes what about the
69 000 people on the street that are not
spreading the disease
you're putting them back in homeless
shelters so they're not spreading the
disease
again it doesn't make sense his whole
reaction i asked him make
me mayor make me deputy mayor i will
come up with the covert answer with you
i i will put all the communities
together i'll get leaders from every
community i'll threaten them i'll scream
at them
i'll create an independent coalition
go from door to door in each of our
communities work with our people come up
with ideas
and solve the problem the man does not
care we're the mask
i think it's because you're approaching
this as though you think bill de blasio
shares the same values you do
you think he cares about people you
think he cares about kids you think he
cares about the homeless
i don't think he does that's his job i
think absolutely it is
but i think he's just he cares about
himself he cares about ideology he cares
about
enriching his family you look at his
wife what did she get a two million
dollar staff budget
when the city is being shut down and
people are losing their jobs his wife's
got a staff
total like two million dollars a year
she what does she have like an artist or
something someone like paints for her
yeah that this is this is what it this
is like it's it's
what kind of government is it what do
you call it is it when you've got the
rich people
by the way hypocrisy plutocracy the the
wealthy take control
they strip away the rights of the poor
they enrich themselves and they laugh
about it they laugh in your face they
watch the city burn
and they're doing it i can only imagine
on purpose you can't have all these
riots
sweeping through the city and then bill
de blasio cheers for the protests
and across this country we see the same
thing in michigan we see in california
they march with the protesters they
cheer for it after they burn everything
down
kamala harris asks for donations for
rioters then she comes out what recently
saying oh the poor small business
what do you mean you have to bail out
the people who destroyed those
businesses
it's it's it's crazy to me that from the
start with cove in the lockdowns
15 days to slow the spread we all agreed
turned into what
what he just now the businesses are
are destroyed but you know you know it's
crazy you get a lot of businesses a lot
of perishables
food restaurants they were gone first
but what happened to the hard good
stores
all these stores that sold shirts
clothing branded gear
skateboards electronics well they were
fine right they could they could they
could stay
shut down until this all ended and then
the riots happened smashed all the
windows stole all the stuff
ripped these businesses off that
finished them off then
kamala harris bails them out many of
these leftist democrats bail these
people out cheer for it the politicians
the the governors the mayors march with
these people then
finally things are calming down what
happens well we get an election they
announce joe biden's the winner
they all come out dancing the streets
celebrating and it says you know
people of the world take notice
americans dance in the street
celebrating
and then a week you know not even a week
later three days later they're like
people
are start traveling for thanksgiving
shocking the world right
these are the news stories that we get
all of a sudden covert is back you know
they're telling me now i'm i'm here in
your maryland when i go back to new york
there's going to be people at the
bridges
and they're going to make me sign a
thing and take a cover test when the
sheriff pulls me over i'm going to tell
him to kiss my fat behind and he can
take my test when he finishes licking it
that's what i'm going to tell him
nobody's going to tell me what to do you
know
governor may de blasio's daughter was
arrested for protesting too
yup she got out on a desk appearance
ticket which was like two hours later
me for the same thing that i did i had
to sit overnight in jail
you know his wife loses a billion two
dollars billion
1.25 billion dollars no questions asked
a couple of years ago about a year or
two ago we had a big police um
investigation and corruption a couple of
them were arrested
uh some uh personal bribed uh
uh police there was some private jewish
guy matter of fact from my community he
was one of the leaders of this
of this criminal act very close to de
blasio and everybody was accusing and he
himself
testified on the stand against other
people and he testified that de blasio
got money
blasio wasn't touched wasn't arrested
not investigated
how don't worry about it when i get into
city council babies i'm going to
investigate i'm going to bring it back
he thinks he's going to get away with it
never he's going to get away with it
so guys i am getting into city council i
don't know how
i don't know how i'm going to do it but
i'm going to try i'm here because
i'm not going to sit back i'm not going
to allow them
to and i'm going to repeat this over and
over to you until it gets through
everybody's head
you know i tell everybody watch my show
just enough history show wednesday night
like i keep repeating it
i want people to get it into their head
you can't hurt another person
it's it's a shame what they do to the
little people and
and and tim i want you to come with me
one day in my neighborhood
to some of the homes that i visit they
don't have anything
i can't go to new york or quarantine
we're going to trace all your family
members too but i i see people that when
we deliver food on a friday package and
my box
you know the city was giving away free
food you should have seen it they gave a
box with a dirty bucket of yogurt
a a a brown banana and some cereal this
is what you give to your family
my boxers have chicken i mean i can't do
more we do only 137 families but there's
other people that do more families we
have such
good volunteers you know american i love
america i love america with everything
that
my my my blood runs red white and blue
but again america has its issues we have
a lot of sin and
corruption and and if you believe in god
he would have punished us he should have
punished us
but the greatest thing of this country
the greatest why god won't touch us
why god has rewarded us we do the most
crested we call it in jewish the most
weak charity the most
generosity in this world every every
city every place where you go there are
charities from red cross
to doctors growing freebies people
giving food that's why i tell people i
tell it to the young people
you think you have to do big things you
have to change the world and it's so
good when they do
i love when they do these young people
and i go to different
ethnic communities and i see these young
children trying and they're doing great
stuff
helping children go take in a kid and
study with them for an hour
go visit an old person once a week go
into the nursing home that's what i do i
have one lady i visit once a week
she's so happy when i get there for that
hour you wouldn't believe it
it's like a different world for me and
her bring a bottle of milk
to some old person that needs it or to a
young family
my box lasts my people till sunday and i
know
and i've been telling you the truth to
him and i'm embarrassed to tell you that
they they they scrounge and they skim a
little bit of food and
they have children some of these people
have three four kids so they try to make
your last until monday tuesday and i
tell them not to
it's wrong because we know you need a
real meal
you need a real breakfast you need a
piece of chicken you can't just have
a leg and think that it's good enough
you need to give the kid a sandwich
you know my kid came home from school i
paid my tuition i have private school
for my kids it's called eshiva that's
what it's a regular school
and my kid came home one day and he said
pop didn't have lunch so what does that
mean
we paid for everything and my tuition is
for ten dollars a day for the kid
and uh i called up the school screaming
at halloween and they and to say well
you didn't pay
his lunch i said what are you talking
about i have the receipts oh we made a
mistake between
your kid and another kid i said so
another kid is not going to eat
i mean is that your answer to me so i i
went to the school and i spoke to the
parents of my kids class
and we saw that there were three kids
that couldn't afford the lunch program
and we put together the money it only
was like three dollars a day for all of
us parents whatever
and we made sure that those kids had the
food this is what other people do to
other people
it's unacceptable this great country
this
wonderful land we've we've built you
know
after the revolution how how we helped
our neighbors build our homes how we
rebuilt america
yeah civil war was bad but again abram
lincoln stopped it
told everybody no no go home we're
buddies again
stop it and we built this nation back
piece by piece brick by brick we went to
world war ii and we defended
the rest of the world not once twice you
know i want to tell you a funny story
not really funny for me it's a serious
story
i have a cousin called getzel schwartz
he passed away about two years ago
uh maybe a little bit more and i'm sure
you've seen the movie in glorious
bastards oh yeah
uh so it's a you think this movie is a
fake movie it's a true movie except for
the ending my cousin
lost 10 members of his family wiped out
in the war
killed and he and his father survived
they made it to america he couldn't
speak english but it was a big tough you
know these big tough built european guys
and uh my mother made it to america with
ten of her
she only lost two my father lost uh uh
most of his family except for a sister
and another sister that couldn't have
children she was operated on
but getzel came alone and he came to
america right at the beginning of the
war
and what do you do with him he couldn't
speak english so he joined the army
and he was a jewish guy was a little
prejudicial back then
so they made him a paratrooper to jump
behind enemy lines i figured you know
the jew boy will be dead no time
this monster of a man jumped mission
after mission after mission by an enemy
lines and i sat there as a little
six-year-old boy with my cousins the
girls
telling us stories how he got behind
nazi lines cutting their throats
stabbing them going back out
and we listened to his stories and they
were true because he had friends that
lived it
was a monster at 70 years old he was
still doing 100 push-ups in his
underwear
like an animal at the end of the war he
had medals like you never saw before
i've seen them and he found a sister
that survived he
he got to the concentration camp almost
in time they killed her four days before
wow he had a mental breakdown he went
into town he took his gun and started
shooting germans
wow and um they of course grabbed him
caught marshalled him but he's a hero
medal's up to a zoo so they dishonorably
discharged them all honorably just tell
me he got a pension
and he left the army and he went home he
married a beautiful woman
and um what he did was he went with his
wife to israel
and it happened to be 1945 1946 when
again
israel became a state 1948 and the war
broke out
what do you think this crazy man did he
joined the israeli army wow
became a hero was a big time
hero he had a house in israel a house in
america two pensions back and forth good
looking man
and every time i saw him i i i couldn't
believe him when that movie and glory's
bastards came out i
i said this is my cousin this is one of
the boys i'm i'm confused though uh you
you're saying that you you had family
you you uh
lost family in the holocaust yeah but
you're a donald trump reporter i was
told by the left that trump is literally
hitler and he's a fascist oh please
come on i mean i've seen i mean i'm from
new york city he has
people in in in in low-income families
that he he lets
live for free or he helps out his
charities everybody messes up
everybody's a business man
everybody screws up everybody makes
mistakes he has got a team around him
you could talk to him about his
accounting
the man is the boss the boss the boss
puts out work people make mistakes
i like donald trump i believe he's an
honorable man he's done
more in one day of his life than i will
ever do in the next 10 years
you're you're from new york city yeah
brooklyn new york lived there your whole
life all my life
you were there uh in the 80s when donald
trump came in and started
taking the city back that's right i saw
him build that rink when he told koch
you're building a skating rink for six
years you can't finish it the man came
in in a few months
and finished it under budget wow stop it
guys
stop it i don't know what you're telling
me because the guy knows how to
uh pitch his product because he's a
great salesman wow i
am proud of him and when he ran for
president i couldn't believe it i said
why
why would he do it and i'll tell you why
they're going to tear them apart i don't
care he didn't care
he did it and this is why i believe he
deserved a second term
he took the ridicule i mean come on tim
russian collusion you believe that the
president of the united states is a
russian spy
i mean did you actually believe obama
was a a jihadist
you know i mean you guys are crazy i
mean we we're crazy sometimes the way we
think
but you actually for two years i'm
watching this he's a russian spy
we're going to impeach him because he
actually is russia flynn cooperated with
really it's a shame what they did and
they wasted 40 million dollars
this guy muller is an idiot i mean he
doesn't deserve to even have a license
or to be even respected
nadler my little fat i'm not gonna call
him a name i know tim you're gonna kill
me
but i have so many good names to say if
you let me say it tim you'd make me
happy i'll give you a dollar
i have ten bucks in my pocket you only
get a dollar i need nine bucks for those
tolls
right guys nine bucks anyways so um i
hate this little nadler man and he
he's did you ever see him when he got up
on the stage incompetent the way he
spoke the way he pitched his case
i mean it didn't make sense and then
they voted against party lines only one
idiot switched sides
romney i mean impossible and you knew
you weren't going to convict him
so you wasted another 10 15 million
dollars in the whole country's time
why again tim somebody's got to explain
it to me i don't understand there's a
there's a series now i guess it's called
empires of new york yeah have you seen
it i haven't seen that
it's it's it's like it's praises donald
trump is that my understanding
talks about how he like rebuilt the city
and came in i saw a documentary
a year or so ago that it was about i
think it was an old documentary it was
about the 80s
and new york was crime infested the
trains were riddled with graffiti people
were scared
uh people were getting robbed and then
robbed you walked down williamsburg we
have a section now in williamsburg which
was very high priced now to buy a piece
of
apartment is a thousand dollars a square
foot oh yeah when you walk there is when
i was a kid
if you weren't raped robbed stabbed
or you made it out alive really didn't
make a difference woman a man you are
lucky
i had two brothers who um had a
warehouse there the father had to wear
us a little shoe company they used to
sneak in
and and all the the ladies of the
evening i want to say the bad word were
there
and it was like they told me they they
couldn't get for their building maybe a
few thousand dollars
when all these fancy high-priced stuff
when it was so bad there
now they got millions of dollars they
sold it now to the yuppies oh yeah
but we've rebuilt the city donald trump
he's a businessman he has to make a
profit don't get me wrong i sometimes
don't agree with all his policies but
he gave jobs he gave you a chance to
make a living you wanted to be a
millionaire well don't work for him
but he gave you a chance to at least to
pay your bills and that
is what this gate great city about
somebody else can make money he gives
you an opportunity
take your opportunity if you don't like
it go away you know i have many guys
that i've worked for that
abused or knocked me or tried to cut my
prices
or didn't let me make a dollar i said
hey man i have a right to leave you or
have a right to take the job
i don't do business that way i make sure
both sides are correct
i like it that way i want i make a
little bit less let the other person
have a life
when uh when trump started running i was
actually i went and covered a bunch of
the trump rallies
and i went down i think one of the
things that definitely insulated me from
the trump derangement syndrome media
was first trump starts doing rallies i
go and i actually met trump supporters
talked a bunch of regular people
and then all of a sudden i hear from the
left that trump supporters are all crazy
violent rednecks and i'm like oh no i
met a lot of these people like regular
people
and then the other issue was that i went
to trump tower and i've been to trump
tower
several times living in new york even
before trump was talking about running
or anything like that
and then you know you go to the ice
cream shop you go downstairs i've gone
to the restaurant you get a nice trump
steak or whatever
you bottled water and when trump was uh
you know getting
smeared and attacked in the media i went
to trump tower and i just you know went
to you know
you go down the escalator they got the
ice cream shop right there in new york
and i asked uh like so you guys know
trump and they're like yeah he comes
down every every so often and i was like
what do you think
cool dude and they're like oh that guy's
great they tell me stories about how
trump would come down and drop a 100
bill in their tip jar all that kind of
stuff he's a good guy and so i'm like
i think he's got a mouth for sure i'm
sorry this is america
i'm allowed to say anything i want i i
keep forgetting the first amendment
the second amendment the fifth amendment
we got a lot of amendments for a reason
he's allowed to say anything he wants
except if he's on youtube you can't i
heard that i got that
but do you know what's painted by the
way when you went to trump tower right
there in front of trump tower do you
ever see where those black lives matter
now
to paint your sidewalk curb cut you know
what that is when you go up into your
driveway that little curb cut
to paint it yellow is illegal in the
city of new york
if you do it it's a thousand dollar fine
serious god forbid to paint your
sidewalk or
to block no parking mayor de blasio
painted black lives matter on an entire
block and not won two blocks
how do you do that and doing it
illegally doing coffee he's the mayor
you can do whatever he wants
so of course somebody in my community i
don't know who was running around
parker or painting yellow all lives
matter for a couple of days oh wow
i wasn't sure he was they said he was a
chubby guy
with his shirt on top but it wasn't me
it wasn't you i think it was linda my
wife
yeah no you're beautiful and you're not
chubby i love you i'm joking i'm in big
trouble tim i hate you
why are you letting me on this show i'm
going home
lindy's not letting me home we're gonna
make a supercut of all the times you've
said something about your wife
just put it together in a big five
minute string you know i i make fun of
everything we were drinking wine the
other day and uh
and we were just sitting there nicely
you know we don't really drink but we
were having a nice little
wine watching our television and all of
a sudden i heard i said and she said i
love you
i was so happy she never really just
says that i said wow linda i can't
believe it just know i love the wine
little witch i hate her so i got a
question
um no i do i love you baby i need
i it's not the money it's not the money
i'm joking i think uh
i think we need police i think uh police
do a very important job i think they get
i think they need better pay for one i
think it's got to be
considered to be like a higher like we
got to treat cops better but
i have to say thank you i say thank you
when i see every police officer
they need that they need you know
because police officers do have issues
too they have family problems too but
here's a problem
who are these cops that show up to
arrest you who are the who are these
cops
that are defending and the black lives
matter painting is illegal
the mayor doesn't have the right to just
go and do that in violation of
i mean he essentially stole taxpayer
dollars to fund the creation of
and the defense of and it only functions
because he has
police officers who say i don't care if
it's illegal or not
i'm going to protect this guy committing
crimes correct so how do you how do you
deal with that so
there's always somebody you know most of
the cops are great but there's always
somebody
i don't want to bring that i found 27
cops who would do it i i don't want to
bring up the nazi time but you know even
back then
there was most a lot of the people did
not agree with what
hitler said but then there's always
somebody that wants the money to move up
in the ranks and you have these idiots
these two warrant officers
hey wow here's an opportunity the mayor
called us we're going to do what the
mayor says of course we'll be loved by
the mayor
this is a problem you having a protest
is constitutionally protected
you and your community gathering is
first amendment protected for a variety
of reasons
first of all peaceably assemble very
under under the police guidance they're
the ones who set it up so so
you can peaceably assemble and you can
practice your religion that's
both of what you are doing they come and
they arrest you
de blasio without approval
in violation of covet guidelines paints
in the street
obstructing a road taxpayer dollars
cops defend him they arrest you who did
nothing illegal they defend him who's
clearly breaking the law
again that's a problem he you know by
the way i i i don't want to tell you but
one of my one of the uh holidays we
before the holy
holiday of yum kippur where we uh
cleanse our sins
so what we do is we in the old temple we
used to
sacrifice uh an animal a sheep a goat
and uh you take it and you cut it up and
you give the meat to the poor people
we can't do that today so what we do is
we have a chicken
and a chicken we can all eat right
everybody has chicken fried chicken
like a rotisserie chicken right yeah you
can do whatever you want so what we do
is we
have a way to to sacrifice the chicken
in a very
uh um uh non uh
it's in a way that it doesn't hurt the
chicken even though pita comes and
screams and challahs
but we do it in a way just like a
butcher we do it but we do it we we take
this chicken we make you pay eight
dollars for it or twelve dollars
and we make a blessing on it to take the
sins of your sins and we put it on the
chicken
and the chicken dies for your sins and
we spread the blood it's a
it's just a stupid ceremony it's not
voodoo it's nothing crazy
and we take this chicken we clean it and
we give it to the poor only the poor you
cannot even though you pay for it
you cannot have the chicken it goes into
a box and it gets distributed to the
poor people thousands and thousands of
chickens
and it goes for the holidays wonderful
thing um so i was joking at one of the
uh
you know one of the paces the police try
to shut down this thing with pizza and i
was blocking it and where i
am they leave it alone and uh i was
joking with one of the chickens when
they tried to make me you know cleanse
my sins and
i told them i don't have any sins linda
has a lot of lists of sins of mine but i
really don't
have linda i really am a good guy baby
girl i need more money
really i'm broke anyways so um
the uh so i did this and i joked that
i'm gonna chop off i'm gonna chew off
the neck of the chicken and de blasio i
might do the same to you was a joke
two cops showed up at my house saturday
yeah you want to kill de blasio i
videotaped it by the way they said you
can't videotape it harold
i said i'm gonna videotape anything i
want but i brought him in i said really
are you watching my videos
and the cops told me we watch all your
videos
i got a whole new bunch of people
watching me you know what i mean
your views are through the roof and just
cops watching you waiting for you say
something wrong
i guess so i mean they're watching to
see if i'm going to kill them are they
crazy i mean i have a history of
non-violence
i do not condone violence i work for the
police i work for the city i work for
the department
uh hpd i i i go to court i help the
homeless
i don't understand you look at my
history of that i've worked with the
police
they know that you're right i don't
cooperate with the district attorney all
the time when
when people are injured or they're
abused women i will not tell them when
they run away or something happens i'm a
big boy
i know when somebody does something
wrong sometimes they have to be
given a second chance and yes a third
and a fourth chance my father told me
people allowed a thousand mistakes and
about 12 big mistakes
but you're allowed to make mistakes and
if you don't believe me go call my wife
i got lots of
she has a list she has got a book man i
notice authorities
love to catch people on technicalities
that's it like uh michael flynn didn't
get him on a technicality so it wasn't
even it was like jones they got him on a
technicality they loved just
right finding that one little thing and
then what's wrong with the president's
what's the president's friends that were
was arrested with
also with 20 cops his wife was deaf
roger stone
rajasthan raided his house at four in
the morning cnn was there and waited
amazing
beautiful job guys wonderful you got to
live in this
this like fantasy well not fantasy but
like uber protective
you got to protect your speech we do
have the freedom to say whatever we want
but that doesn't mean that we should
if you create a platform and you support
the likes of de blasio and these
democrats who are breaking the breaking
the rules of breaking law
if you support say black lives matter
you can go out and street
so i i remember we were talking to some
dude a guy who lives in new york as a
comedian
and he was saying that when the black
lives matter protest started it was like
i can finally go outside
right so they all go like this is it i
can go outside now and they're like i
just want to want to be
locked up anymore so that's that's kind
of how they they like if you support
their cause you say their words
now you're walking out you're going for
a walk everything's fine you're not
getting sick
and then they put out this study i don't
know if you saw it they said uh uh
they said that the black lives matter
protest actually reduced covet yeah yeah
yeah now
the trump gatherings no no no no that
made everything worse it was it was the
black you know
the politics changed the nature of the
virus as it were they made people sick
they made people you know i had a doctor
on my show a doctor karen bernard she
said
if she's a psychiatrist a child
psychiatrist is locking people in the
houses they lose it
they lose it and now some people now
actually believe never to leave your
house
and if you leave your house you're a
spreader if you don't wear triple masks
on your face you're spreader
you know when the masks came out they
were seven dollars a piece now you get
them for zero
you know um by the way every person
brought in to cover it into the hospital
where
mike and i'm telling you for a fact now
i'm not talking about all the other
hospitals i don't know but i'm telling
you for a fact in my mamani's hospital
39 000 every time they wrote down the
word covert
20 000 if he died fifteen hundred
dollars to the ambulance people that
brought him in
there was a a twitter thread that a
bunch of journalists were sharing where
this one journalist said
there's a conspiracy theory among people
that hospitals financially bene are
financially benefiting from kovid
but many of these hospitals are
struggling and
it was you know it was basically the
story she was putting out where trump
supporters don't believe covet exists
and you know i responded with it's not a
conspiracy theory
usa today ran a fact check saying if a
patient goes to the hospital
they get paid more if they're marked as
coveted exactly
really if they're if they're put on a
ventilator they get three times
i forgot that i'm sorry thank you thank
you for watching usa today ran the fact
check they said it was true
are we crazy really tim am i crazy i
mean something is wrong
and then the reporters all came down to
beaupoc to the jewish communities
because may de blasio told them all to
check and they were filming
anybody who didn't wear a mask
eighty-five percent of the people were
mad but some of the kids didn't want i
never wear a mask i just want you to
know i don't wear a mask
you can forget about i'm never gonna
wear a mask yes when i go into a store i
have my just in a fishing mask you know
because i want to promote my show that's
the only reason why i would wear it and
pretty much i send linda in because i'm
never going to go into places but most
of the stores
you don't need to wear it be respectful
if that's what they want that's what
you're going to do
he's lying there even even a fouchy says
the masks are no good anymore now he
wants to shut us down you know there was
one new guy one new
somebody the new health guy for for
biden wants to shut the country down for
six weeks
first we say 14 days then we say a month
now six new weeks we're going to shut
down the entire country the entire
country dude it's
the lazy bureaucracy and these people
are acting off
they're treating us like robots they're
reading a script of numbers and they're
saying if this number of people
stays inside for this many months then
it will equal this many less of this and
it's like
look at the humanity of what's happening
to people that can't
get out of their house and how they're
going crazy and how people will kill
themselves and they're looking
exactly but you know what they're doing
they're going let's see if we do the six
weeks we'll have
17 000 suicides and if we do that's
acceptable
now guys that's what they're saying guys
take a look at the big picture
now even if we're locked up no wedding's
allowed
so that means nobody can get married so
there's no children to be born i know
what you're going to say we can do well
anyways but
most of us want to get married we want
to have the wedding we want to have our
children while we're married
now you're telling me people can't even
go on dates you know i
i actually saw a couple of young couples
going on on dates with masks how do you
even look at each other how do you talk
to each other
now forget going on dates we're going to
do a zoom date oh please really
a zoom date get it away from me i gotta
go talk to the woman i gotta spend time
i gotta go
play ball with a bowler you know have a
pizza with her
but this is what they're trying to do i
think they're trying to control
our i guess our population i have no
idea
i think i think it's probably less
specific than that but that is caught up
in it it's the great reset
yeah it's a lot of these uh it's not a
conspiracy i hate that word by the way i
hate it
the great reason i hate it it's i mean
justin trudeau
right the new yeah the new normal the
world economic forum said coven 19 is
our opportunity for the great reset
to uh fix global capitalism so that
stakeholders you know
get more involved or whatever and then
so i think these politicians are like
now's our chance so i think we had we
had a really really bad covid
you know earlier this year we saw what
happened with china the question that
needs to be asked right now is look what
what about these other countries you
know china recovered you know china is
fully open
yeah no no no no vaccine wow
wow so what i think is in my opinion
that uh kovid's around
and uh i wouldn't want to get it it's
got lingering health effects there are
people who
lose their sense of taste and stuff and
a friend of mine just got
got covered and he's got he's got
symptoms it's like he can't smell or
whatever
that's freaky but it doesn't mean we
shut down the entire country
over it so what i think happened is it
was novel earlier this year a lot of
people got it it was spreading like
crazy guess what
15 days to slow the spread it worked i
think we saw
everything go back down everyone back to
normal but then instead of saying okay
congratulations everybody we did it
they said just keep it locked down and
then these democrats start saying hey
we can use this exactly and that's what
they've been doing
so i think we should take it seriously
but i don't think seriously at this
point is go
is going against the world health
organizations you should always take
your health seriously nobody you know
in the summer time it's raining and
people run into the house soaking wet
and they go to the air conditioner
in the winter oh i want to look nice and
pretty and they wear the skinny little
dresses you know the girls
i gotta wear they're beautiful i'm
making fun of you women i got you
i know you have to wear those thin
little see-through dresses
but you know don't make fun of me but i
i and i don't look at that if i'm not
supposed to but i do look it's terrible
i'm jokingly i don't know tim please
send me home i can't be here anymore
so uh my point to you is is take care of
yourself wear a coat
i wear a coat i wear myself a sweat
jacket in the winter when it gets rained
yes i'll suffer and i'll take off my
clothes and i'll change it if i don't
have a change of clothes you'll suffer
because you're going to get sick and if
you want to get sick it's going to get
worse
and that's what you have to do you must
take care of yourself go home and take
your tylenol don't be a big shot
go take your your your your your your
aspirins go to a doctor
for your for your every six month
checkup you know people make fun of me
oh hey she
you're a big fat guy you're dying i have
my blood pressure 120 over 80.
nothing can get to me okay i'm a perfect
health i gotta lose like 900 pounds i
know i know
damn i can't win anything can i look
like you you look so good
you gotta fast try it i love him don't
you say i love him i really love it he's
a good looking man
obesity what is it sixty percent of uh
americans are obese right now
and where that were uh is completely
related to this epidemic
yeah uh oh it's stuck at home it's a
co-morbidity you know and people who are
stuck at home
uh people who are obese are have are
dying of coverage so let's talk about
that
but you know life is so short you know i
want to tell you a story you know i was
today at uh
the uh abraham lincoln memorial and um
i love abraham lincoln one of my
favorite presidents i'm a historian i
love history i love
the past i i love learning about civil
war i
i do a lot of research on world war ii
of course and
abraham lincoln's own life and when my
son was born
i wanted the name him abraham lincoln
tishler you know would have been cool
right
but of course linda won that woman is
just
you know i'm looking back 31 years i'm a
loser
god that girl beats me every which way i
love you baby
i love you i'm coming home don't worry
about it anyways so
um my my um my father passed away when i
was young his name was abraham solomon
and i was a little depressed i had to
get up from the seven days of mourning i
had to take care of my family
passover came and it's a true story and
if you don't believe me you can ask my
nephews my family
and i had to make the seder a sader is
um
the the the when we when we got out of
egypt
we were slaves in egypt so we came out
and we became free
the jewish people at 3 000 something
years ago so every year on passover we
make the seder this remembrance dinner
of our freedom from egypt and i got out
of
when i got up i was 13 years old i was
the man my father passed away the day i
stood up for morning was the day of the
first seder
and i had to make this seder every year
for my mother and my brothers
once i married off my brothers i took
care of my mother i helped her
recover her family i did some good
things for the family
so i i got married linda found me she
tricked me into marriage
no you didn't die i was joking she
didn't trick me she did and
uh so anyways we got married and we were
pregnant with our first child
and i told linda i don't want to be
religious anymore i i'm sick of this
passover
i want to change i'm a new man i got i
took care of my family i moved my mother
to a new home i did everything good
i took care of my sister i want to run
away and my mother begged me she says
hashi
it's one more passover give me one more
say that i said mommy
i don't want to do it anymore i really
don't want it i don't want to be
religious listen you're doing it to me
for 14 years
give me one more i said okay mom and now
seda usually takes three four five hours
it's a ceremony it's a meal
family around you i said mom you got 15
minutes i'm a pro at to say it already
i'm doing it in hebrew and english and
and hungarian languages i can do
everything anyways we're having to say
that i'm flying through the seder
and my wife is not due for about a month
and all of a sudden the middle of the
seder my wife gets up and says
hes the baby's coming i said oh no no no
no no baby's not coming for a month
quickly i called the doctor and the
doctor's baby's not coming so i
put the doctor on the phone my wife as
she's threatening screaming and using
bad language
uh the baby's coming and the doctor says
it's not coming and even if it comes it
takes 10 hours
we hung up on the doctor and i stopped
putting on linda's shoes as i put on the
second shoe plop
he falls into my hand this little piece
of nothing garbage
the placenta falls out linda passes out
the baby's dead linda's dead
my mother's screaming in a language that
i did not know that she had coming out
of her mouth in bad bad words blood all
over me blood on the floor
it was over and i i just saw my eyes
before me then i look down and i see
it's a boy you can tell it's a boy with
certain little things that come out of
his body
and uh linda started to wake up and the
baby started to cry and my beautiful
gorgeous sister
called 9-1-1 put him on the phone mean
the police that's why i don't care if
they arrest me i don't care whatever
they do to me
they helped me save my child they came
running they helped me cut the court i
stood on my knees for 30 minutes
i went to the hospital a lot of my
friends were there some of them having
babies said
only hershey comes ready made and of
course
i was going to name the baby abraham
lincoln but i knew that it would be
named after my father abraham solomon
and since then god showed me he says
listen don't mess with me
i'm going to show you passover is a good
holiday i have about 50 60 people at my
passover holidays every year even if we
go down to flower we drag the tables
um it might my passover doesn't in my
state it doesn't end until three in the
morning we have a good time of it
there is a god there is a person that
leads them and i was walking home in the
snow
full of blood i looked up to to heaven
and i said god
you got me you got me and when i got
home my 70 year old mother now listen to
this
says to me i'm gonna live to see that
baby get married
and my two boys were born the third one
afterwards and my second one we
we in the jewish family we don't allow
people just to marry as they please
first second third fourth and my second
son wanted to get married and
he brought himself a woman you know i
love her so much really i don't but i do
i love her my beautiful daughter-in-law
she doesn't like me she
not really you know i don't know why i'm
such a good guy
ian am i not a good guy you're so
handsome
anyways so um he came so we let him get
married my mother said you will let him
get married you know my mother was
you know still the boss around and i was
taking care of her and
we let him get married then a few months
later my older son came
and he went to get married and my mother
came to both weddings
and the day of his last celebration she
died the next day wow
so again guys there's a world there's a
god i will get elected
if that's what god wants i need help of
course if you're not going to do it
yourself god wants you to make a pinhole
he says make that whole come through i'm
not preaching
don't think for religion christianity
muslim buddhist
judaism i love it all it makes this
world a better place
and god wants you to do it yourself once
you do it he'll help you the rest of the
way
i'm here to fight i'm not going to let
tyranny i'm not gonna let my neighbor
get tortured i'm not gonna let my
brothers get get down trodden
this is a special country that was given
to us 200 and some years ago
a gift a gift given to us and we're
gonna let some idiots
take it away from us mr donald trump i'm
gonna tell you on the on on my friend's
podcast him or his show i want to
apologize to you from everybody from the
city of new york if you don't mind
i'm sorry what we've done to you i'm
sorry we've made you suffer
i'm sorry a lot of other crazies in
america has done it but i can talk from
myself my community
i know you're a good man i don't know
how to make it better for you
thank you thank you for your fight i
wish to god that i can come and shake
and bow before you
because you are a true angel you are
superior the rest of us
i don't care what your listeners are
going to scream at me oh you're crazy
trump fanatic
i'm not i'm telling you of a man that
i've seen done good
the country has seen done good over the
last three years even during covet he's
done a good job
what did you want him to do and they
hindered him they stopped our
remember when they shut down the
government budget in the early years how
do you shut down a government budget you
got to agree with your president
for a few pennies they gave out a couple
of trillion dollars in stimulus that's
so nice of you i made six hundred
dollars
twelve hundred dollars what can i buy
for that really you think i can actually
buy enough milk and shoes and food and
clothing for my kids for the rest of the
year
that's what they agreed on keep my
government droning keep my
country running let me go back to work
instead they lock me in my house
then half of us get somehow hypnotized
that we can never leave our homes
and that's what they want they want
people to depend on the government and
that's it we're going to be their slaves
not me not me never and i'm hoping you
children your young generation
stand up it's time not to accept i'm not
saying be disobedient
i'm not saying be violent i'm saying
listen
do your thing nobody can control you and
if the police do
it's wrong there is laws there is
warrants needed
they can't just walk into your stores
and if they do tell them to get out
simple get out i don't want you in my
store why
because your nose is cooking yes
you can't throw me out because you you
know maybe you're prejudiced
i can do anything i want in my store and
my space
but what bothers me what irks me or all
of you people in this country
maybe they're all right you know
everything they said the governor
the mayors everybody that convinced us
the right
but what should have shown you how
stupid they are is that the governor of
new york tells you on thanksgiving
we will enforce you not to have more
than 10 people and the governor of los
angeles of of california is telling you
if you have more than six or eight
people i'm gonna shut off your water
and your electric you now know that's
not normal
just there alone shows you that
everything they've said up to this point
does not count
maybe they had some sense but if once
you're like that stupid i i i you should
jump in the lake
it's time to do super chats super i
don't know what that means it means you
got people asking questions oh go ahead
one for you oh boy
this is from am i in trouble no
president
oh no you're gonna like this he's
talking about it president 34 says
yoheshi you got my vote give him hell
i love you i love you don't forget
heshitishla.com can i say that
yes you can please guys 25 bucks 30
bucks if all of you guys
donate 1000 bucks no no no no you see
little things the little things i don't
need the big guys i don't need the big
bankers
or the big george soros i don't want
none of that money i want my little
friends
across the country give me 25 30
fill up the account let me walk in and
say hey guys i don't answer to nobody
i am here to tell you that i'm going to
make a change in my city and i want the
rest of the country to see what we can
do and who knows
go ahead dis five says as an orthodox
jew living in new york it is awesome
you've got heshi on
thanks to menco oh you got a bunch of
fans yeah i got a i got a bunch of
messages too they were really excited
when they when they heard that you were
coming on
you know i have a lot of haters i just
want you to sure of course
you should see my instagram sometimes
i'm embarrassed to look at it
it's weird how that happens like even if
you're being your best self people will
still i don't know people are jealous
people are angry
eighteen hour days i put in for my
community my own people and then
sometimes they have little kids make
phone calls which i think is cute
because when i'm sitting in the car boys
i listen to their calls
you know i think it's funny it's like
winning resistance like it's inevitable
when you go fast there's just resistance
yeah
noel wayne says new york jews but we are
on your side
mayor of new york the german jews are
the same thing thank you
thank you i just want you to know you're
right and and the mayor is an idiot
and i thank you across this country for
your support i've seen it
you're just wonderful people remember
we're all the same everybody pay
attention
we're all the same that's it
this is crazy dallas tv says tim have
you heard of the skyrocketing suicide
rate in japan
last month they had more suicides than
all their copa deaths
raises the question are the benefits of
the lockdown worth the consequences
crazy yeah me too i have 97
suicides i'm not talking the rest of you
i'm going to repeat it over and over
again
you don't understand each one hurts me
and and this is this year
it's not even over yet i can't wait for
this to be over
it hurts me every time from a 21 year
old kill to a 15 year old girl that cuts
her wrists
or a 42 year old woman that overdoses i
can't
over stupidity we can fix this it's not
right tai chapman says georgia court
grant injunction preventing wiping of
dominion voting machines pending for
forensic inspection this could be
massive
really i thought they reversed the
reversal already
it's hard to track but free nation radio
says heshi you seem like a real mensch
what's your take on jewish support of
the democrats who are leaning into
anti-semitism with omar tolav and
ignoring violence from
black hebrew israelites i'm sorry to
tell you we all have crazies in our and
our families
i i don't know i most of us jewish
orthodox people are normal we have some
retouched that do
switch the sides we have some leftists
which i really you know i was at the
hospital where i volunteer every day
and one guy starts coming out to be
screaming at me murderer murder of a
murderer
i said what the hell i we always have
somebody like you said and and
i don't understand any of my my brothers
and sisters that have at all invited for
biden
or are leftist and i'm embarrassed to
tell you i have family members
close family members that i'd like to
beat the hell out of but i know i'm
going to go to jail and my wife will
kill me
that actually voted for biden and when
we talk about it we get in trouble
at thanksgiving dinner it was a rule
that said no politics
no hugging i said exactly who are you
talking to what did you send that next
to
i hugged everybody and i spoke a lot of
politics
josh martinez says love this guy zero
bucks to say cuomo is an
uh oh no i'm sorry was a 30 bucks to say
cuomo is an idiot one more time
i love you cuomo is an idiot and that
wasn't that's for free my son that one's
free
let's see matthew felton says mr heshee
you are a stand-up kind of guy
if you're ever in nc i'd be honored to
buy you a beer slash meal
the world could use more like you can it
be a kosher meal can we go to kosher
i like corned beef by the way guys
corned beef with coast le mans
in brooklyn we have this great place
called essen the best
ian come down i will buy you the best
not youtube you and because i insulted
you before i didn't really i love you
you know that ian
really thinks not pastrami corned beef
i'm telling we have the best corned beef
by this place on coney island avenue
delicious i think somewhere someone's
saying that you got too much traffic to
your website from shouting it out
and now it's down oh no really maybe
they could check finally
something good is happening which is
really bad that's not good
i don't know guys i don't even know how
to type in my own name sometimes you
know my fingers are so fat you know with
these little buttons you know
all right we got jacob holly says on
thedailytrumpet.com thousands of us
uh thousands of u.s election votes
stored on 47 usb cards have gone missing
in pennsylvania
it won't let me send you the link uh you
can't post the link on here but
i did talk about that there was a uh uh
i believe it was an um navy veteran who
testified the
usb uh usbs with all the votes i were
missing you know you know
tim by by the way i'm signing an
affidavit myself
i was at 12 polling sites which i
videotaped on the day of election
one guy got two ballots another one i
saw her putting in getting jammed the
lady took it out
and said i'll scan it later i said you
can't do that that's illegal
i saw voting machines broken actually
broken
they took your ballot and putting it in
a sealed box and we'll do it later
i said you can't do that why i mean
we're doing this for so many years we
should be experienced
we should have technicians on on hand
you can't just do whatever you want
i saw election fraud myself so whatever
you want to tell me maybe i didn't see
it in the big you
you know humongous ways that everybody's
saying it i saw it
i'm very upset about it and one guy in
seagate new york told me he got 10
ballots
10. one guy in florida told me that they
called him from the station because he
didn't want to come in
he says let us sign your name and submit
it we're allowed to do it
he said no no this is voter fraud
i'm telling you for a fact something
happened i just can't prove it
and i have the stories and i saw it
physically i saw double ballots
i saw the machine broken and i saw them
scanning later on
unacceptable marty says calling bill de
blasio incompetent is a bit of a stretch
of hanlon's razor
but i wish you luck in unseating that
incompetent
here's a bit for the war chest please
investigate events in senior care
centers
why dr lorna breen
yeah senior care centers are not letting
our visitors and
you know somebody's sick in your family
you
you can help the nurse you can you know
i see people sometimes sitting two days
in their soiled
soil and and the nurses don't care i
know they're overwhelmed
you know i know when my mother was sick
i was there every day we had to help her
i watched her
by having family around fistula helps
the patient
second of all uh it just you can help
the nurse
you know because you know more i want
you to know here's a bad story for you
there was a nice man doing covert that
was dying
uh not from covert he had cancer i knew
him he was dying
and we spoke to the doctor doctor you
gotta let the wife and four daughters in
it's true story i videotaped it doctor
was such a nice man at the end he says
okay come
on in let them in nurse came in
screaming cover you got to get out of
here i said the man is dying
it's his final few hours let them sit
here and pray she called security
security started to touching these
religious women trying to grab them out
again we were called you won't touch
them
police came the girls tried to protest
sit on the floor
they grabbed the mother they grabbed one
of the daughters and they tried to take
another daughter to the crazy house
they arrested them for sitting in the
hotel room crying with the husband by
the way the husband died that night
they took him to the jail they were
supposed to give them a desk appearance
ticket
i mean what did they do really tell me
what they did so i went back
later on to the hospital and the
security guards loved me there they said
hey she they're still there they didn't
let him out they didn't give him back a
ticket because i went back
to see if i can help but you know with
the death at the end of certain
ritual rights and i'm pretty good with
stuff like that maybe i can help them
ease through it
they said no hashi she's in the jail
cell i said it's impossible she's there
already six seven hours i went to this
i went to the police station i walked up
the steps you can't come in here i said
listen to me boys
here's very carefully you either beat
the [ __ ] out actually i can't say it i
know i know
you can if you want you cannot i'm not
don't never tell people okay but i'm not
saying anything i'm a religious
guy but anyways i i said you can either
beat me up or i'm going to rip this
building down break by brick and i'm
going in there
and i started to push my way in and the
cops all stood there i said i have no
problem
out came a lieutenant who never met me
before shook mine says hey she
stop as these women are coming out of
jail they're losing their
husband and father and you're gonna let
them sit and rot in jail well you don't
know the procedure i said i know the
procedure
you got five minutes he said what are
you gonna do protest i'm saying i'm
gonna call everybody in my neighborhood
we're gonna scream and holler and we'll
see what happens maybe we'll be violent
maybe not
ten minutes later they were out on
videotape and she went back to the
hospital i followed her there not to
cause trouble and he died that night
wow you arrest women this is what our
mayor has done that we arrest women
whose husbands are dying and the husband
saw
his wife and daughter being pulled into
jail wow
so what do i think guys i'm pissed i'm
pissed about a lot of things
and i'm gonna fight to the last breath
listen to me
alex fiala says heshi thank you for
fighting for our neighborhoods brooklyn
here and love you
you got you got you got you might got
haters but you got some uh i love people
my brooklyn people i love my book on
people i'm getting calls from london
what they're doing in london is
oh man what's going on oh old people
old senior people who are protesting
they're arresting them
they're arresting them and carrying them
into the
into the into these uh police vans
oh senior people that are protesting
that everybody else allowed to protest
but again easy easy come you could just
push around the bullies to do whatever
they want
i think you got to think bigger hashi
rotting flair says lived my whole life
in suffolk county over three decades
and you're absolutely right about all
the corruption please run to replace
cuomo so that you can clean up all of
new york
and so that i may have the privilege of
voting for you wow i love you
i love you i love you i want you to know
something i i i'm a man who's focused
and i've always
uh had a had a vision or i look at the
light at the end of the tunnel
and i work where i promised that i could
do best
right now i know that my focus
especially
with my my uh experience i can get into
the city council
when i can show you people that i can
can help not control
never control and not lead guide my city
fight my city to make it better i got
eight
million people in trouble i have five
boroughs and i'm talking jews i'm
talking uh
black people italian people asian people
i they come to me
i take care of all the communities
muslim people i'm in churches mosques
this is where i want to fix it you're
right 2022
there's a governor election i'm not
going to run but you know you never know
what happens but i'm not
looking to be everybody wants to be
something bigger a billionaire they need
20 billion 70 billion
i'm happy with what i have i know my
goal i know if i can fix my
city i can work and help and guide and
give advice to other communities and
other towns
new york is my town everywhere in new
york is my town
right now it's the five bows that need
me badly and need me to make a change
clean sweep
and maybe maybe the other little
communities will fight back
and and make their own changes that's
why then i will be there
right on hershey schwartz says thank you
tim for having heshi on the show
thank you for shedding light on very
important issue keep fighting the good
fight you are going to heaven
you know his name is heshi by the way
hashi did you just say that
you said it oh hershey well it's how she
hershey
some people have have referred to as
hershey right but i i assume that it's
typo
it's no because in the old country it
was hershey or hershey and we switch it
but you know
uh but sometimes the people don't know
how to say my name i say hey hershey
like the chocolate but i am delicious
right yes of course i like this girl i
like her so much
do you got somebody here who can help
with your website because people are
saying they want to donate but your
website's down i'm gonna kill about you
better call somebody right now
isaac tell him that the website is down
i'm gonna break his neck call him on the
phone right now
yeah wow i can't believe it guys don't
forget don't give up i'll fix it i'll
fix it tim needs me right now
okay he's buying me dinner we'll figure
it out well we
yeah actually actually yeah yeah i love
you tim hey spade says
heshi clean up the new town canal
ah there's a lot there's a lot of
comments saying they're trying to donate
but they can't because your site's your
site was there
a donation method uh uh there there was
uh uh it's called it's called uh zelly
is that zelie
zell it's called tishler family at
aol.com it's the only other thing but we
wanted it through the website
where i killed too many people i know so
many people are trying to come in
wow i love you tim did i say you know if
we get ian is handsome you're better
looking
all right tim is good looking he is
look he's blushing don't blush him i'm
not gonna grab you behind don't worry
about it
anna didn't know that it says i'm joking
guys i'm joking
so so i agree with this uh anadin says
love this guy reminds me of trump
yeah i was gonna say something you gotta
you gotta you gotta trump kind of thing
new york you know i i wanna tell you
something i love donald trump i love our
president
and you guys think that i agree with
everything i don't agree everything my
wife says i don't agree with everything
the mayor says
i have problems with donald trump i i
don't agree with him on his immigration
i don't agree i believe this is the
greatest super
country in the world there are so many
immigrants that are here that are lost
i i can't throw them out and you're
right let them get deported they did
crimes
come on some of them did some stupid
things we all do stupid things as kids
i have a problem and i love my present i
believe he should build a wall and i
believe people shouldn't be walking in
here as they are here
my problem is forget the new immigrants
i have people that are here that are
trapped here
and i need to work with them we can't
just
tear it apart and i believe that mr
trump also believes that i believe that
we're just not understanding what he has
to say so again but i agree with most of
his policies
wonderful what he's done and i'm i'm on
my side but again again i have my own
mind too
and i believe what i have to do there's
more from ended in though he says
outspoken says what he thinks my company
sells garbage truck
to commercial haulers in new york city
and a few of them had to cancel because
restaurant waste is way down
yeah wow oh by the way um the jewish
schools
have we have a lot of garbage so what we
asked was we do daily garbage we do pick
up in new york city twice a week by the
way
in your front to your house you know you
have your regular garbage and you
recycle garbage
and that's the way it works you put it
out one day you put it out there then if
they don't come you have to pull it back
in and start all over again
our jewish schools have a lot of
children like any school and we need
daily pickups
so we had an argument with our
department of sanitation after
begging and finding money in the budget
we finally raised enough money for
my neighborhood to get a special truck
to go around
all of a sudden the department of
sanitation a woman comes in says
you know what um um i want you to
recycle but not recycle this
new thing organic recycling you ever
have this organic recycling
something new uh crazy a little brown
garbage can we're gonna give it away for
if you don't do it we're not gonna give
you a garbage truck
we said are you crazy woman i i mean you
know what it is just
to do the regular garbage recycling and
the daily garbage she punishes and she
pulled out garbage trucks out
sometimes you have garbage coming out of
schools with with three four
five hundred kids sitting there for days
of smelling they don't care
they're out for their own good that's
why when i become city councilman
those little commissioners they're gonna
come in i'm gonna make them miserable
they're gonna answer for it
and if they if i can't fire them or make
them quit i'm gonna
curse so badly i'm not gonna not on your
show not say bad words but idiot and
other bad words are gonna come out of my
mouth
they're gonna run they're gonna leave
because i'm gonna make them sit there
daily i'm gonna question them
that's the committee i'm sitting on not
90 committees i don't need lanza means
committee i'm big committees
one committee i'm going to torture them
i'm going to defund them i'm going to
put proper people in place
and exposing them on your show is key
because i do it all the time i try all
the time
i scream i holla i put out videos i
stand in front of inspectors
and they call the police and i follow
the inspectors and i say to him what are
you doing
and sometimes they fight back sometimes
they scream and i follow them i said
what are you doing you're picking on
stores you're lying they're not you know
one store got a violation of having
three people in it with social
distancing
they broke the law i saw somebody too
close i said really you saw somebody
less than six feet apart in a big store
three people
they just had to issue the violation and
tim i told you before
you know a store in my neighborhood got
a violation because
he left his door open for some fresh air
nobody in the store
no chairs no tables nothing going the
store wasn't even open yet
guy comes in he says it on the violation
well we'll answer for it
one school got a violation for not
having children there
empty you're on the list
that was the answer thank you mr de
blasio thank you
nicholas osbourne says long haul truck
driver here i started listening to your
content right before the rona appeared
and i got to say
listening to you has given me the
ability to debate on a level that i
never thought possible keep it the good
work
appreciate it let's see awesome human
says for heshi question
i was vetted for a job in saudi arabia
was told to leave off my mom's jewish
maiden name
also told i'd be banned if i visited
israel how excited are you they might
reach a peace deal with israel
wow i mean come on guys do you
understand what it is
peace do you understand nobody to die do
you understand that the world
maybe will become a better place
especially when we get rid of de blasio
and cuomo
but really a better place you know my
father was around in
in in the 60s he marched he was a good
man
and look i know i know don't get me
right don't get me wrong i mean i know
we
still have a lot of issues and we have a
lot of uh
prejudice in this country but it's come
a long way
i'm so proud of what has been
accomplished and you know who i give
credit to
jared kushner donald trump and by the
way under donald trump's leadership any
new wars pop up
every other president has a war so
founded donald trump no wars
he's still bringing up our home our
soldiers he's saving their lives that
they don't get killed anymore
thank you superman if he wasn't scared
of green rock says
if not me then who if not now then when
ian tim lids you have my
kavadh respect this guest is fantastic
uncle heshi you remind me of my saba
shavuotov and
totoroba thank you for being a zadek
in a time when we need needed one the
most he said
uh it was so nice i pronounced my
pronunciation was awful no no you did
great he said
uh after the sabbath you you wish
somebody a good week
and he also said i'm a holy man which
you're wrong i wish i was i wish i was
better
i really try and he wanted to give us
cover his respect
and uh he's really this was a very nice
saying thank you thank you for me and
thank you for the tim
he said he was very nice this time what
language was it it was
uh yiddish hebrew oh yeah
he did very nicely and he wished us uh
uh such good things he wished us
and he wished us thank you that was so
cool and you said it you really did it
you did it better than me scb says
haihashi
i like you and support your fight
against cuomo and de blasio and i'm
working with someone to develop a
merchandise company centered around
politics and would love to work with you
no one should have to endure this i i
love you i'm always open to help
somebody i'm always
hoping that i hope to help somebody make
money i want people to do well and if
anybody could use my help in any way
and it would be my pleasure to help you
my pleasure
uh please any time you can contact me by
email justinfi
gmail.com uh my phone number is all over
the place i'm not scared but you know i
i can't pick up every call
you can whatsapp me text me instagram me
what's the other thing tic tac youtube
you're on twitter yeah yeah yeah yeah i
have a quite a bit of fun i can't
believe it i just went crazy
i love tic tac toe have a good responses
i thought instagram was cool but tic tac
is
i'm a tic tac fan there you go yeah
matthew holly says has she accept
bitcoin and contact larry sharp
okay no problem i i don't know what that
means but okay thank you
you can put a bitcoin address on your
website that people can donate to
wow yeah oh wow and they just they can
copy it paste it and then
send a bitcoin beautiful adventurer says
former code enforcement officer
i was forced to resign for bringing up
fifth amendment violations in a rural
uh county it happens everywhere
unfortunately yeah we have we have a
couple of
good men in my community code
enforcement officers that are retiring
and quitting because they won't put up
with de blasio and and their their
commissioners forcing them to do
illegal they actually quit i couldn't
believe it i i speak to them some of
them are my friends
and they're hiring new idiots that have
no idea of no training you know we have
people who are building department
inspectors that have never lifted a two
by four
you have guys that are plumbing
inspectors are telling guys like me that
have been in the business for 30 years
how the pipe should be situated and bent
when he doesn't he's never been a
plumber
or put together two pipes but he knows
how to read a set of plans i had one
lady inspector who so badly hated the
jews she goes from
i've been following her she sits down a
one-page easy plan for three hours
torturing us
and i don't even know she's ever even
glued tile to the wall and she's telling
me how to build my building
dan austin says new york got the best
pizza and the worst mayor
giuliani was the best i love it you know
i go to a pizza shop every saturday
night there's a guy who does it
i actually love pizza i love pizza guys
so i try to go to different pizza shops
me and linda you know again i'm broke
so the best date i got is pizza at night
for linda it's only eight bucks you know
what i mean on a soda
i would buy you a steak but linda likes
pizza too is it is it brother's pizza
just a buck
we don't need to not coach be our
pizza's 3.75
yes you know so for two slices plus a
soda
me and linda have a good night listen i
take her out of the house
and the gas and the toes i know i'm
cheap guys what do you want for me i'm
broke
is it the cheese that's kosher it's the
cheese you know cheese
at the end of course it's made in an
oven that's not mixed with any meats
and is watched constantly that it's only
made for dairy products
you know it breaks my heart to see what
they're doing in new york city because i
lived there for five years
and uh good memories a lot of fun
hanging out with people
there's always a different neighbor you
can go to a different kind of food you
can get venezuelan food
yeah in new york it's great ethiopian
food kosher indian food i never had
you know we never had sushi when sushi
came out a couple years ago
i'm addicted we never had we could never
have sushi because it's not good
not kosher but now they figured out a
way with the fake crab oh wow
i make myself my own i make the best
crab salad and the best
uh schnitzel which is you know chicken
cutlets yeah
my mother um taught me when i was a
young boy
how to make chicken cutlets and french
fries and that's how i tricked linda
really she didn't trick me
i tricked you with food you know women
are easy no i'm joking
she tricked me so i made her that she
says you're the best cook really that's
all i know how to make
chicken cutlets she figured that out
after 31 years cynthia
hopefully i pronounce that right it says
heshi president trump is very pro-israel
i'm worried that biden will destroy all
the good that trump has done for israel
and turn america uh and in turn america
will lose its blessings what's your
opinion yeah
so let me tell you that is correct we're
all worried about that but here's the
deal
um you know people don't understand even
if trump doesn't get reelected which i
believe he should i believe he can and i
believe he will
but god gave us a gift trump shouldn't
have never been president everybody was
against him from day one
everybody said he had no chance election
day he lost by 90
and look what happened he gave him to us
it was a gift for four years
he gave us israel by moving our our
uh embassy he's helped out us in the
peace come on middle east did you ever
see and they're not going to give him
the
nobel peace prize at the end of the day
i don't think biden could hurt them but
israelis are tough people
it's a tough country uh you know women
there in that country
are more successful than anywhere in the
world the biggest chance in israel
if you're a woman entrepreneur to
entrepreneur to be very successful
israel is equal to everybody they're so
great
i of course they have their issues like
every country you have the religious the
secular everybody fights with one
another
but when it comes down to the bottom
line when they're at war when they're in
trouble they stick together
and i know every inch of that land and
i've
again i'm an american boy i'm a jewish
man but i know that land
i was there right after 1967 in 1969
after the war
and i was climbing in jerusalem over
garbage piles where today the properties
worth hundreds of millions of dollars
then you could have got it was like
warland i was climbing over garbage i
saw tanks blown up on the street i was a
little boy
and i go back now and i'm in awe of how
they built that land up
deserts of cities and and i'm proud of
them and i know they're survivors and
and a lot of the the holocaust survivors
who built that country
uh uh wonderful people i'm proud of them
and it's not only them
i'm i'm i'm happy saudi arabia is waking
up
i'm hoping their human rights issues are
going to change as well
the mistreatment of women you know we
have that all over the place
there's so much strife so much
tribulation so much troubles in the
world
we've got to fight the battles one at a
time and you know you know the
you remember not the red cross what did
what did uh kennedy make way
we sent people all over the world the
youth people uh uh
some organization in the 60s you know
young people went all over the world to
help the world the peace corps
the peace corps i can't believe it what
a great idea that was right
just going out to help people look how
great america is we could do so much
yeah we could we could build water wells
and like solar-powered water
condensation all over the world i
i'm with you man i think we should use
this blessing of the us
right and you remember if you ever guys
go back to the 20s and 30s
india was a country that was starving
people were dying we figured out a way
and american figured out a way how to
to create more we to make the country
more development
right brilliant right look what we do
we have to help one another this is what
we do we take care of one another and i
promise you
we will watch for you and and that's our
job little things guys
little things i'm not asking for a lot i
know a lot of you guys are going to make
fun of me oh here's the old guy telling
us
oh he's got to do good i'm not asking
for big things little things
this was my policy the last 30 years and
i'm stepping up now
i promise you i'm going to win this
election not for me
not for you for the people that need us
the people that just
need a little guidance a little push you
know how many young people with just
a little bit of education or a job or
just
i i worked in the projects and i told
you there was a lot of drug dealers and
stuff like that
and one guy came to me for a job i gave
a lot of people jobs in the projects he
says hey i don't have gloves or boots
i'm going to go back to sell drugs and i
right away gave him some money but his
drug he was one of my best workers ever
and matter of fact to this day my kids
killed still call him uncle greg
and he used to take his kid around the
project i watched him do
it i said hey i got to keep him away
from the drug dealers i can't let him
take the shortcut
i want him to see i was so proud of him
look what a father does it's out you
know
you take on a responsibility in life you
just don't quit
you just don't leave oh i'm finished i'm
old your responsibility your father
you're a mother
you're a boss you're responsible isn't
your job doesn't end when you're doing
community service
you know i'm not a big fan of obama but
he had the greatest line that i've ever
heard
service to your country is not just
serving in the military is to serve your
fellow man
be a tutor be a teacher feed somebody go
to a soup kitchen
i go to a soup kitchen once a week
sometimes they throw food at me
sometimes a little crazy
and my son was there sometimes i get
embarrassed i said hey
why do you think we're here they need
our help if they were all great and
perfectly in the houses
everything will be pretty our job is to
help one another
and i promise you guys i know you want
50 promises what i'm going to do you got
zero i'm not making
any promises zero get it out of
everybody's head i'm gonna do my best
i'm gonna fight for my neighbor and i'm
gonna do what i've done for 30 years and
i'll never be one of them
all right last super chat go ahead
stephen hatchy says heshi
love your courage and conviction i'm a
san antonio firefighter i wish we had
you as mayor here
i by the way i love my firefighters i
take pictures of my i have a firehouse
next door to me
and they come in to me all the time they
take pictures they're my best friends
and i come there whenever i can i i i
bring a little bit of food or pizzas
they're so great they're fi you know
these are men that you know every day
could die
they put their lives on the line for us
these are not these are not
regular people these are not these are
superman these are men made out of steel
and when they pass by your house you
guys should ev
not only the policemen firemen are the
greatest people on the planet
i've seen them go into burning buildings
are they crazy
they must be crazy because they're
actually run into burning buildings
gotta love it to kill it i think i know
i've seen them save children i've saved
families
giving mouth to mouth and and i don't
know what and i've seen it myself
i'm telling you i love firemen i really
do i should have said that to you before
my firemen are the favorite people on
the planet i'll tell you
anybody these uh these people would run
into a skyscraper that just had a plane
smash into it with debris falling from
the sky people burning
and they ran into it and uh man those
firefighters
it's it's sad story they risked
everything either are they crazy
or the or the angels a little crazy no
no no
my dad was a fireman and his dad no he's
a little crazy they're not crazy
they are angels you don't understand
this they're selfless
i grew up with it and that's the beauty
of it
this is what we have to teach out you
gotta love it to kill it
doesn't make it you gotta love about
anything anything you do you gotta
i i personally believe you got to
struggle through life and until you get
to something you do great
but of course you have to love it
especially when you're putting your
lives on the line how come how
embarrassing how could we all have a
firefighter video game
i feel like that would be a third person
video game there's an atari game
but like imagine like but imagine like
you know really good graphics
and it's just a firefighter and you're
going in you're up against the heat and
the eye
i mean that'd be a cool game a vr game
dude with the smoke clouding your eyes
you get duck down not even that
complicated just like different
scenarios of a firefighter going in and
i want to be a partner in this action
here maybe i can get some money that
could be an acceleration right you could
fund the campaign a little bit
heshitishla.com i know guys i said it a
million times just remember it okay guys
i'm broke what's your social media uh
i am uh i see it on your you got it oh
yeah so it's called just enough heshi
gmail.com that is my email and of course
i have just enough she twitter
just enough hashi instagram just enough
she what's the other thing facebook uh
she teaches like harold tischler what
else do i just one more thing uh youtube
justin yeah i got to it i got twitter
yeah even though there's a couple of
fake twitters just stick to just enough
as you guys there you go
and that's it and and if you want to
contact me i tried to get back to
everybody
sooner or later i i do pick up calls
leave messages i know the messages get
full
i do i do serve my community to the best
that i can
and if i can't i will try to get you
somebody else or send you to the right
place
listen i got a lot of experience on
behind me i'm not a big shot
i'm not going to tell you which doctor's
going to save your life but if i don't
like something i'm going to tell you to
stay away from it
i'm telling you not to go to the
hospital because there's a reason not to
go to that stupid hospital that killed
so many people
i have a guy danny who lives by me he
was on my show and people didn't believe
me
he says has she saved my life i didn't
save him all i did was said danny you
doctor said you're going to die here i
have a spare apartment
come home with us linda and he will take
care of you he lives by us to this day
he thanks me all the time
i said there's nothing to thank me for
you know just pay the rent
there you go that was a joke it was a
joke that's fair yeah
so uh you got a show right nine o'clock
on wednesday wednesday nights nine
o'clock
it's on youtube uh and facebook uh it
goes out live on youtube and fake calls
just enough hashtag you can subscribe to
it
and uh we do you know we rerun it
afterwards or you can always get it
and it's on channel a local channel
local lady station called 6
20 a.m wnsr it's a regular live station
has like about a hundred thousand
listeners and um
yeah and i try to cry and and complain
and
and tell the truth and of course my my
my
show always starts with a quote and a
joke i have a quote of the day and i
joke and yes
the joke is always about linda there you
go yeah so when i sometimes it's a bad
joke
and i know the door is double acting i'm
in big trouble linda
i got flowers hashi thanks for for
hanging out with us man thanks for
letting me come down it was great i had
a great day i met some great people in
baltimore
i got a free meal by the way some guys
treated us to a meal wonderful wonderful
guys
and i almost got into the white house i
think i still might get back
but i tried to get in but the secret
service isn't you're too fat
no but uh you know thanks for thanks for
everything else you're doing in the
community and fighting for
and when you guys come to brooklyn come
check us out i will show you around
i will show you what he's done to my
town and i'm not running away i'm
here to stay i'm here to go i promise
you i'm gonna do a better job
and i'm hoping and i'm praying to god
yes i'm praying to god that it gives me
the wisdom and the guidance
to to do well and i thank you thank you
for letting me come you're wonderful
guys and ian i really do believe you
actually
okay i love you can i tell you i love
you you know i wasn't picking on you
tim told me to do it he's an animal i
know the show's like you gotta just tear
you up yeah
yeah friends you can follow me on
twitter instagram parlor at tim cast you
can check out my other youtube channels
youtube.com
timcastandyoutube.comtimcastnews you can
also follow ian yo homies smash that
like button and follow me at ian
crossland anywhere
anywhere on all social medias can i say
smash that like button say yes
smash that like button baby goodness
grace
oh god you can also you can follow lydia
you can you can have sour petulant i
feel really quiet now sour patch let's
l-y-d-s
and uh you want to do a shot of the sign
real quick we got it all set up and nice
for uh for for
that oh actually there you go right
person
right person fighting for you check it
out hashtag thanks for coming on the
show
thank you so much and uh we'll have you
back somebody by the way lydia you know
i i love women i was not making jokes
for the women i
i respect women very much okay linda i'm
in big trouble i gotta meet linda you
are
i gotta meet him no i don't really let
anybody see linda you know what i mean
everybody knows linda because i talk
about it but she never comes out to the
public i took it to once to a park
and when we opened up one of the parks
lindelin they were all running after
linda not me i said i'm the hero idiot
i'm the one no no linda's the good one
damn her
all right everybody we're back tomorrow
at uh 8 p.m live so make sure you
subscribe hit the like button hit the
notification bell
uh thanks for hanging out and we will
see you all tomorrow at 8. all right bye
guys
you